what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not just
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do going out
having fun get out okay okay then then
get out then get out faster then get out
I'm not here to get
most men want a woman that has some
degree of femininity where they feel
like they're taking care of taking care
of I'm lady night I'm submissive and
you'll be surprised because I will say
what I want to say now and I'll say what
I want to say with my mind but my
demeanor doesn't change and I'm gonna
look down on him because at the end of
the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened to
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I would feel so bad asking a
guy to buy like a three thousand dollar
bag
cookies
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell the way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in as that is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams okay a
couple announcements before I start the
show um if you guys have any questions
you want me to ask the panel make sure
you Super Chat them we are going to be
reading super chats every 20 30 minutes
so
um but you have to do a super chat over
how much blessing
foreign
over ten okay super chat's over ten
dollars we will read
um also guys
um make sure you subscribe to two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
also we have four membership tiers um
how many likes to open up the chat today
one thousand okay a thousand likes and
we'll open up the chat guys
um to get to be a part of the chat make
sure you sign up for our first tier it's
five dollars a month also guys our
second tier you get to be a part of our
Discord and our behind the scenes blogs
if you want to see me freestyle rap sign
up for a second tier third tier you get
to connect with me on social media and
fourth tier you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month also guys they
banned my Instagram so go follow my new
Instagram just pearly things one they
also ban me on tick tock not one not two
not three and not four but five times so
make sure you go follow my new tick tock
which was exciting they gave me my old
username back just pearly things also
guys go subscribe to wife school we have
an episode of me needing bread so if you
want to learn how to knead bread go
subscribe to Wife School actually I'm
gonna do this again who here knows how
to knead bread
okay thank you I'm this is my point is
proven someone told me that people in
England know how to need bread and I
knew I was being gaslakes I've done this
like three four shows barely anybody has
said yes I knew it
I think it was Auntie who told me that I
was being gaslit okay
um also guys make sure you go subscribe
to Auntie Jenny and King Richie's
channels
um and if you want to come on the show
make sure you follow the pregame page on
Instagram there's only one official
pre-game page and we also have members
only videos so make sure you sign up for
our memberships and we have meetups that
we're going to be doing this month so if
you want to meet me and the crew make
sure you sign up for our Google form to
join our meetups it's an email list and
your phone number so you'll get texts
and email updates okay guys um we have a
lovely panel welcome to the show
um so today we're going to start with
your age name relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here
and then go around
good my name is uh Jay Johnson
I'm single and a fun fact
I recently started a podcast as well
what's it what's it about
it's about things that would plague the
mind of the Modern Man and it's called
Modern Man mindset do I know episodes
out or just recording at the moment but
yeah very soon
um my name's hope I'm 21.
um
name age relationship status um I'm in a
relationship and a fun fact
um I've been on a reality show for BBC
I'll go ahead or go home would you did
you go harder did you go home I went
home but
but I'm like episode seven there's ten
episodes so by episode seven I went home
okay um but yeah what was it for so
basically it was a reality show where
eight young people who are like
struggling in life go to this tropical
island to complete like amazing tasks
like I've climbed up a cliff like
climbed out of caves
um like opened cages and oceans that was
amazing and it was my first ever holiday
I've never been on holiday so that was
oh wow that's awesome yeah what was your
favorite challenge you did
um
definitely the um cave one actually so
basically we're in a cave and we had to
it was like a dark cave and we had to
build our own ladder out of bamboo
sticks and make our own way out I cried
so hard it was so embarrassing but I
ended up doing it so I was really really
proud of myself question yeah did how
did the women versus the men like was
there any difference in how you guys
handled the stress yeah it was
um I feel like with the men I feel like
they were trying to act a lot more
braver than they actually was whereas
with us women we kind of let out our
emotions a bit more but obviously they
will succeed in more than like the
physical challenges but when it came to
like more mental challenges we you know
we smashed them like what kind of mental
challenges did you guys win so there was
a tug of war one so we're basically had
to pull them up and then once we pulled
them up we have to run and do a puzzle
um the men flopped so you guys did the
puzzle yeah we did the puzzle so good
they did good on the tug of war but we
did the puzzle like so good um but yeah
when it came to More Physical things
they were obviously better but just
emotionally I feel like we let our
emotions just a bit more than them cool
very very interesting very cool very
nice fun fact I like that go ahead
um Vivi I'm 24 I'm single at the moment
and um fun fact I always got an issue
with those last time I said that I was a
tattoo artist today I'm gonna say that I
don't know maybe I'm into Neuroscience
oh you're into Neuroscience okay that's
it yeah what kind of Neuroscience so I
like to kind of experiment is science in
general I think is really interesting so
I kind of like to experiment kind of
compare things and see if I can find out
something on my own as well
um so like how the electrons and photons
kind of work in a similar way and things
like that it's just yeah and I do on the
side cool and you said you're a tattoo
artist too yeah so yeah I said that I
was um kind of on a podcast before yeah
okay yeah that's it go ahead hi my name
is Prince um my age is currently
redacted and what do you redacted
now the women
come on we know
um I'm currently 40 and fun fact about
myself is music is my life so I used to
be a producer for Dipset and now I just
produced for UK artists and myself wow
I'm a rapper you know oh wow so
hopefully we can work on something after
yeah yeah yeah they do things mixtape
coming soon I do I do a very mean rap
yes so yes that sounds great enjoy some
bars on a freestyle
go go ahead uh it's me the notorious MLD
uh 37 recently single and fun fact about
me I went to the HMS Belfast and the
Imperial War Museum today it was pretty
cool ah okay
um I'm 35 I'm single and a fun fact
about me
I love camping
what's that funny is it
um do you camp often where do you camp I
try go once a year in this country
because we don't get a lot of good
weather but you'll get one week where
you get really nice weather and I'm down
by the beach with my tent
and my dinghy and your ear dinghy yeah
okay that's fine what's dingy it's like
the ocean thing right it's like a blow
up boat yeah yeah oh cool
um okay so today
um we're gonna have a conversation about
dating yes yes yes
yes I know crazy
um so my first question
what is your ideal first date
oh we start with me yeah okay cool you
did get this seat today this is the
starting seat no I don't uh I would say
something kind of Outdoors definitely
multiple locations not necessarily
eating involved I don't think people or
humans in general look particularly
um attractive when eating but um yeah
something Outdoors um I Love A good rule
of Terrace you know I like to see like a
Skyline you know you got a late one by
the way
um yeah so yeah something like that
maybe somewhere in the woods or
something like that something to do with
nature and yeah an activity that
actually allows you to you know bond
with the person and what could a girl do
on this date that would make you not
want a second date
uh I mean if she's just on your phone
too much I mean almost on your phone at
all like unless it's like a massive
emergency I think the most important
person is like the person right in front
of you you should pay attention to them
um you know especially in a date
scenario where you're literally vetting
for this person whether you know you
find them really attractive or arousing
or what kind of long-term or short-term
interaction you want to have with them
in future I think it's important to be
present in that vetting process
what about you ideal first state the
beach okay the beach sunset Ocean like a
little picnic blanket yo yeah the beach
I really like that I know I know you're
in a relationship now but if you were
dating again what would be something a
guy could do on a date that would make
you not want to speak to him again
um
trying to act like you know when a guy
tries to act like he's the man but he's
like he's proper really trying to let me
know like yeah I have money yeah I have
this [__] so being super like cocky like
in your face about and most of the time
when I like that they don't actually
have what they're saying they have like
yeah yeah so it just it just gives me
the ick like I don't like it even if you
do have money
um I feel like that's not the reason why
I'm there right now like I just want to
kind of know you yeah what something a
guy could say like what would he say
like he would mention his car or like
what what's an example just for the guys
watching like what not to do on a date
okay for example um so this isn't a guy
that I was dating or anything but we're
just talking
um I work in a nightclub so he was like
trying to like talk to me like that
um and then yeah he was just telling me
with every single conversation if we're
talking about houses would be like yeah
yeah my parents have three houses but
obviously I don't really care about
money or like we'll be talking and he'll
be like yeah like I have about 10
watches but I don't care like yes you do
you care so I kept bringing up the money
yeah
you know it's a crazy thing for me when
guys bring up height when like I won't
bring it up I'm like well I hate girls
that are shorter than me like I just
like I mean I hate girls that are taller
than me they'll just really make it a
point how tall they are but I just I
don't like them no it's funny it's like
because I don't usually bring it up but
if I'm taller than a guy even if it's
but like because if it's a little bit I
don't really care but it's like I'm like
why are you bringing this up like I'll
tell you I'm six foot I'm pretty tall
yeah I'm very tall uh so what about you
ideal first date ideal first day I think
um I don't I'm not really into like
dinners or anything fancy or anything
like that I think the best dates that I
have been on involved doing something
that is going to help so like I don't
know let's say um there's not really
much time I live in Brighton um a lot of
the guys that I date are from London
um so if we get a chance to kind of meet
it's normally on I'm quite a busy person
and that sometimes they're quite busy as
well so if we get to meet it's normally
when they have to go and pick something
up from somewhere like help the family
or you know so when I if I can actually
see the guy in his like natural
environment as well I could literally
consider that a day or even go into like
Ikea or something you know or go into
the radio first day it's like here I
think do you know what I could actually
say that because I was I I've asked a
lot of people would you be up for going
to Ikea at night you know
um kind of quirky but yeah so why do you
date guys from London if you're because
Brian's like two hours from here isn't
it an hour and a half that's pretty far
like why is there something wrong with
the guys in Britain no not really I just
I tend to I don't know I just tend to
date guys that from it just happens
they're just from London you know I'm
just wondering what makes them better
than the guys in Brighton there's
there's nothing okay you can't really
like say that so what happens is
for some reason let's say if I'm on a
dating app most guys are from London
that that's all that's all that happens
and I have dated people from Brighton
before it's just you know it's just a
majority are from London that's all okay
and it kind of first date I would give
you the egg the egg yeah like something
that could be a big just for the guys
watching so I would say don't bring up
other women
um that's one
um or in general I'm quite
um attracted to intelligence so if
somebody's Loki stupid that really just
ruins everything yeah
okay
what about you
um well at this point in my life
um it's not so much about the activity
it's more about the connection so we
could be doing anything we could be a
meal or having an intimate like date
where I cook or she cooks or whatever
it's more about just the connection so
as long as we're genuinely engaged and
laughing and just having a good time
then it's a good date pretty much you
know what I'm saying
so where would you take her oh I think
an example of where you could do that
well
something like ice skating
or something like golf mini golf there's
tons of places like in London for stuff
like that but generally anywhere where
we can have a good conversation and
actually get to know each other we can
pretty much happen anywhere but um yeah
mini golf
um ice skating
a good dinner something like that and
what the heck
guys don't really get the egg but but
like what a turn off anyways being into
not exactly having any thoughts of her
own and being to and everything she does
being dictated to her by her friends or
social media that's a just a hyper turn
off for me like what's something a girl
could say to you that indicates that
she's just controlled by social media ah
what do I bring to the table
a good one
Brenda check to the table is that common
have girls said that to you often on a
date
um well because
um I'm pretty much traditional so I'm
used to paying for everything and
whatnot but um I have been in situations
where somebody thought I wasn't being
engaged in at the time
and
um
that's because I'm I'm more I tend to be
more gentleman like or reserved in
certain situations
um
that's not necessarily a turn off but I
do realize that different people expect
different things and whatnot in
relationships and stuff so in a way it's
almost bad for me to say that I'm
someone being into social media maybe
um
a turn off for me and stuff like that
because everybody's different but social
media and all that stuff is definitely a
turn off yeah
MLD ideal first date and what's a turn
off
something that's low effort like
something like a coffee or like a couple
of drinks at a lounge that way if I like
smell crazy I can get out quickly 45
minutes to an hour uh if she starts
talking about her ex in any way on the
first date I'm just like I'm mentally
checked out and I'm like already
strategizing how to get the hell out of
there is that common you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised so he's nodding too
is that from the guys comment how often
do girls talk about exes on a first date
too much right away yeah I would agree I
mean yeah same same as you were I would
just like check out be like yeah it's
not gonna happen I've never had that but
okay how how do they bring it up they'll
just they'll just bring it up yeah I
feel like one of them go
no they like some of these girls like
you sit down you're like ready to have a
good time she's like you know my ex used
to like no be addicted to XYZ I'm like
oh okay I know now I know why you're
single like so now anytime they start
like when when the date starts to turn
into a therapy session yeah I start
drinking and I mentally check out and I
look for an exit as soon as possible
yeah I mean I wouldn't say it happens
like pretty much all the time or but
twenty percent yeah I would say that no
more often than you think yeah I would
say like half but it's just like every
so I often it will happen and you're
like okay cool I know what this is yeah
uh what about you ideal first date
and what could a guy do to give you the
ick
uh I like something a bit more likely
like a walk around the park with a
coffee nice chat
um and something that would give me the
ick is
if
if he
behaved in a way
where
I'd feel slightly embarrassed like a
behavior likes trying to put someone
else down to make himself feel better or
to look better that kind of makes me
feel a bit like I want to get out of
here I don't want to be here anymore I
mean to the staff rude to the staff yeah
stuff like that it's really not nice
so the people that you guys go on dates
with where do you typically meet them
oh
um so you can start Portage I'm in
shoreditch
I went there last night I understand
that reference I get that reference my
tongue slipped um yeah I mean I guess
some dating apps you know it's kind of
like sales always sourcing and you know
I mean I'm in like music and
entertainments you just always around
people a lot so yeah just from being out
I guess what would you say is the number
one place what is it dating apps mutual
friends or a shortage
laughs
well that's a tough question dang
um
um I would say probably shortage because
wow I should hang out there more to be
fine I live there and I do a lot of work
there so I guess that's why but yeah so
um is there a difference in the quality
of women you meet through each place
like where would you say it's the
highest quality quality in terms of
short-term or long-term potential
long-term potential long-term potential
I mean I would say probably somewhere
like what you said yeah more like
low-key and relaxed I think girls who
you know um let's say aren't constantly
looking for a lot of attention all the
time I think they tend to be better like
long-term Partners so just anyway I
don't know maybe like a library or
something I'm really in libraries you
know but I'm just I'm just using my
imagination
so have you ever gotten a date from a
library
um actually you're never there
actually
I went on a I went on a date with a
really wholesome girl and she's like
would you like to see this library and
like she showed me her book collection
and we went to this line yeah she was
actually a really really sweet beautiful
nice girl I was surprised first time in
my life yeah I mean they've been few and
far between
um
you just said it like you met girls
there and I'm like wait you just said
you don't go there no no I'm just using
my imagination it's actually because a
friend of mine said this to me like the
kind of girl you meet in shortage is
different you know on an eye out to the
kind of girl you meet let's say a
library oh it's short it's not a high
quality I mean I'm not just saying that
like we're just being out I was attacked
oh yeah I saw that yeah I was attacked
so I don't know the women I haven't been
impressed with shortage women but that
was my samples it was like midnight you
know
um okay what about you
um
yeah where do you typically meet um I
know you said you have a boyfriend now
where did you guys meet
industry
he just saw me in the street and he
approached me yeah like just a porchman
and and before that where did you
typically meet guys like where was the
biggest street
I'm noticing
I don't know like when you're walking in
the street and then someone's like
yo can I have your number I don't know
like okay so he asked you for your
number yeah no yeah yeah he was he was
very weird of it he kept on seeing me
like in the streets every single time he
saw me would like to speak and then he
eventually asked my number okay like did
you walk by him on your way to somewhere
yeah the area that I lived in it was
like it's a very tight-knit area like I
would see him if I come out again so
yeah what about you where do you it
sounded like dating apps earlier yeah so
dating apps I think 50 50 because I get
approached quite a lot on this street as
it is and Brighton I mean we've got you
know nights out there's a lot of like
clubs and stuff so when I walk down the
street to get to the beach to hang out
with friends um there's always a lot of
different guys coming up and stuff you
know
um so mainly this but I think yeah I
would say
yeah more on an app because I think it's
just more automatic
um but yeah but I think meeting people
in person is more organic and you can
actually tell you know what they're like
kind of the first impressions and
everything straight away so yeah so you
prefer you think the quality is higher
it's much higher when you get you can
feel them out you can't feel them out
through the apps you can't put a filter
in real life too yeah
what about you
um to tell the truth I don't do so much
of the app thing at the moment but um so
it's more daily life and things like
work so for the firm I work for we're
always hiring and firing people so
um I'm always meeting tons of people I
was off for a month
um a couple of weeks ago when I came
back there was tons of new girls and
stuff and because
um I don't know if they have bad taste
or I'm genetically gifted um I tend to
get um a lot of attention and whatnot so
um when I have time I sift through
the potential suit is and whatnot so I'm
work in the street
pretty much so wait let me get this
straight so you're the place you work
will hire girls and you'll date them and
then they'll get fired
[Laughter]
um
where I work anymore
[Applause]
it's kind of convenient if it doesn't
work out like
um for instance so it's summer right now
so we just had a ton of uni students
come in for summer jobs and whatnot um
ladies and the ages of 21 to 27 and
stuff and
I love them like older guys and stuff
like that so um we end up talking and
stuff and yeah sometimes it goes forever
sometimes it doesn't and where did you
meet your best relationship at
um
I don't think I've had that yet you no
number one draft pick
um like tomorrow you got to get married
you got to pick an X
that might oh that might have come from
a dating up dating app okay
what about you MLD I think the majority
of women I've met and date it came from
dating apps
but recently with my newfound internet
Fame it's been Instagram
so Instagram is a little bit I don't
know I think dating apps now are just
flooded with [__] people yeah like I
think early dating apps it was good
times but like now it's Whale City and
craziness everywhere yeah that are bots
so yeah but I I definitely agree like
meeting them organically in the real
world is probably the best way okay
and where did you meet your best
relationship
she was the secretary at my job oh no
way yeah you know I have a friend that
says that you know who it is but I have
a friend Ally she says if you want to
date a certain type of guy to try to
work for them yeah she's like if you
want a dentist go be like a dental
assistant now she was the best girl ever
dated my life
what about you
um now would be dating apps
um but it wasn't always like that I
think when you're a bit younger it's
easier to get on with people like
friends of friends Associates things
like that
um that's where it was when I was
younger but now dating apps working okay
for me okay
when
is the best when is the ideal time for
you to have kids and get married
that you guys would want to do that hmm
would you know that's an interesting
question because if you asked me like
two weeks ago I probably said an older
age but I think maybe sometime a bit
younger like
it's changed in the last two weeks
that's a good question I guess it was
just coming to terms with the sort of
future I want to have and kind of Legacy
I want to have ideally a big family so I
mean if you want that ideally you know
you want to start early obviously as a
guy you know you can keep busting nuts
till you die but like you know
um the earlier you start you still got
like a good better chance of having a
bigger family which I think would be
really nice okay how old are you
prefer not to say if that's all right
okay
he dodged it did I I think you did huh
you cannot say you're finished
okay I'm 25. oh you said that earlier
yeah yeah you did I don't remember my
bad I don't know so you're 25 so you
want like the next like four or five
years
yeah I'd say so yeah okay cool what
about you
um preferably when I'm like 28 29
but I just want a kid like when I'm
financially stable so if I'm financially
stable by next year I wouldn't mind to
have a kid okay but just when I'm good
like when I know I can give my child a
good life you know do you have a
boyfriend though right yeah yeah but so
what about would you ever give up your
job to like just stay with him he
working
um
okay so I've always said what I want to
do in the future anyway
um I want to be like an Entertainer like
content creator he asked me what I want
to do in the next four years like I want
to have a talk show so I've got like
really big dreams but I've always said
if I generally didn't have them dreams
um I generally wouldn't mind giving up
my job looking after the children being
a housewife so I'm good with that but
it's because I've got like proper big
big big dreams that I just couldn't I
couldn't give it up like no way
Minecraft
myself yeah
um
I think there's a
we've got biological clock as women and
men have got Financial clock when it
comes to children
so our biological clock I think is until
we're kind of fatty that age maybe after
30 out of my photo I don't know exactly
but we start running out of the ability
of um kind of having kids even though
it's possible for a woman when she's 40
something to have a child
um the quality of the eggs is not as
great as we know
um same with men so I think
um same with men as in financially so
they have Financial clock so once
they're capable of providing for the
family obviously this is when they start
thinking of you know settling down with
kids so I think having
um being 24 I think I still have a fair
couple of years to you know to to think
about that but then I'm thinking I
wouldn't really just have children with
anybody so it's it's a really tough one
nowadays because I really want to have
somebody I know I'm not going to leave
and that I'm secure in a bubble with
somebody I can trust that I can raise
really good kids with you know okay so
what age would you like to do that
ideally 90 of your eggs are gone by 30.
yeah geriatric pregnancy starts at 35.
that's yeah if you're single by 30
you're more likely to not have a kid
than have one yeah that's true so just
knowing those numbers what age for you
would be ideal
if I had a child that
26 to 28 I think that'd be that'd be
ideal yeah okay
you gotta start looking now right
I mean yeah I mean you know I'm dating
yeah yeah yeah okay
what about you well um my answer kind of
follows on from hers
um so when my financial clock is at 11
30 then it'll be fine you know what I'm
saying so right now I'm more concerned
about amassing money than having a child
so um when
um with a woman who I believe who shares
the same core values as myself that's
definitely going to make it a lot easier
but I'm definitely more focused on money
at the moment okay
so what age
[Laughter]
well um
to tell the truth
um
I'd be fine having a baby tomorrow okay
if um if the lady and I share the same
core values do you know what I'm saying
okay
but would definitely like to have more
money than I do right now even though
I'm not hurting okay
uh I would say honestly two three years
ago okay I feel like I'm late to the
party uh I just bought into the whole
stupid consumerism thing like oh just
make a bunch of money buy a bunch of
[__] like when you do that you realize
like family's the number one thing that
matters at least to me in my life uh so
I'm 37 now so I'm looking for a wife I'm
like then I'm not out to like casually
date anymore I'm done with that [__] I
wanna have a family I wanna have a lot I
want ideally I want five boys wow five
boys yeah I want a huge family I want a
very very big family so I mean
everything's ready just need to find the
right person now okay
what about you
um I've not
I can have kids and I cannot have kids
in the position that I'm in now and
either way I think I'll deal with it
um so at what age would I have had kids
I don't think I would have changed it I
don't think I would have said yeah two
three years ago five years ago wouldn't
have it do you care if you have children
or not like is that important to you
really no have you always been like that
or is that new
um you see when I was young I thought it
was something that I had to do it was my
job to do something like that
um
but now it's I don't feel so much of the
pressure I think maybe because I don't
want it as much as when I was younger My
Views have changed I'm just curious like
when did it change okay so when I wanted
a like marriage and uh my family and all
of that maybe was 15 16. and had those
ideals yeah so when did you stop having
them when I stopped having those ideals
probably in my 20s mid-20s was it after
like a breakup or something or
it's uh multiple reasons let's say it
could be after a breakup after uh Big
Life Changes maybe work changes mental
changes all of those things yeah I'm
just wondering like what was it for you
because it's just interesting to me
because I feel like most girls start off
wanting to have kids and I'll meet women
like you that that you know they're like
yeah I could I couldn't it doesn't
really matter to me anymore so I just I
always wonder like what sparks the
change like is it your career was really
great and maybe that got in front of it
or a relationship you're in didn't work
out like what happened it could be uh
one of the factors because there's
always many factors one of the factors
is that I want to give my child
at least what I had
and where I can't do that I don't feel
like I
want to have a child and not give it
what I had um so with that I'm okay with
with having children not with having
children adoption I don't yeah that's
open as well but it's not open for
everyone that I do understand
me personally I'm okay with it
I had a question but I forgot what it
was I had a question for you
um
it was what
I don't remember sorry what come back I
know I was like it was a good question
too that's why this is bothering me
um okay how I'm curious on the panel how
many kids does everybody want
three
okay actually I wanna I wanna do raise a
hand so one kid
let's keep it up until it's not yeah
just raise your hand when you when you
are two kids
three kids
three three kids okay
I'm happy with all of you I think I'll
keep my hand doctor okay okay uh four
kids
okay uh four four kids
five kids
oh YouTube Five okay I'd say about six
okay cool cool so
it's interesting though because it seems
like in order to have that type of
family everyone would have probably had
to have started younger right maybe not
the guys with the girls at least
oh [__] you're 21 I'm sorry I'm sorry
she's on the right path yeah
okay what is the biggest challenge you
guys have found in dating in 2823
I'll go first
I would just say General lack of
integrity and a lack of honesty okay I
think that's a big problem nowadays
everybody is just lying you know
everybody's like Flex culture
everybody's lying about how good they
are how pure they are how much money
they make I mean you girls were saying
it earlier like you know the guys that
try to show off on the first date yeah
when the backbone of relationships are
is trust and the number one thing that
destroys trust is lies and dishonesty
like the more you lie the more you're
just gonna set yourself up for
guaranteed failure like I just like when
you meet somebody you start dating them
and they lie at the beginning and then
you find out the truth of these lies
later like all it does is build
resentment and you feel like dupe do you
feel Bamboozled yeah you've been calling
Bamboozled tricked you know so I just
think Integrity is huge integrity and
honesty which I think you know just
nowadays is fleeting and what what is
the top three things women lie about to
you
uh uh definitely body count
definitely body count body count
um
not being over an X
okay
when that guy just casually comes up
conversation like what are we doing here
why are we why are we talking about this
person and then we never do that no no
okay okay and then I just think uh
intentions
you know what I mean like what do you
really like me for so body count body
count hang over an X being over X
intention so I'm curious girls raise
your hand if you ever lied about your
body count
no never have you ever been asked from a
guy yeah yeah and you've always told the
truth
okay
so we got a lot of liars
second second question I don't think
you're you're not obligated to answer
the question I mean you know if somebody
asks you a personal question you don't
have to answer it you know yeah but I
think if you if you want to get a mirror
plug I think if you want to get married
you should want to get married I mean
even in some religions you know it says
that you know you don't have to disclose
that information or anything in fact
that's to do with anything you have done
previously that involves what religions
say that
um Islam
does it yeah you're not obligated to
tell your partner future partner how
many if you have slept with anyone or
how many or anything like that
which is crazy it's very interesting you
should look up
um the fact yeah I've never heard it
yeah yeah I know of Muslims you're not
supposed to be sleeping with anyone
before your mom yeah that is that's a
fact yeah but yeah also if you have
happened you happen to have done
something before you're not obligated to
tell anyone so I'm confused because you
said you'd never lied about it do you
just not answer if they ask you I mean
any personal question they ask me I
don't have to answer
um no I have answered that you have a
question previously yes to to people but
yeah you just I don't think you should
be should feel you know on edge to
answer people's questions yeah that's
all right from the girls do you think
like if a guy asks you that are you okay
answering you don't care raise your hand
if you think it's okay like for him to
ask that she's okay I don't I don't
think it's okay but I feel like I'll
just have to answer okay if I don't
answer he'll be like why are you not
answering and they're just gonna assume
it's high yeah like I don't think it's a
million so I just might as well just
answer but I hate the question on a
first date anyway like if I don't have a
first date there's men will ask you when
they're texting you they don't even know
you like and they'll just ask you on
text do you know why that is why because
there's so many hoes out there lying
that they're [__] jaded that's a big
part of it jaded yeah Jada doesn't like
you know they're just they have a lot of
bad experiences about being lied to
about that stuff because that's a big
thing a lot of other guys uh men value
sexual Purity above a majority of things
in a relationship right and if you're
gonna lie about that it's just like
we're just not it's not okay yeah but
that's why like virgin brides are like
celebrated across all cultures all
religions over all time periods
okay would you want a virgin would you
want to be with a girl that's a virgin
yeah I mean she was if she was if I met
a girl and I liked her and she was like
I'm a virgin I'm not gonna be like all
right [__] get out of here
[Laughter]
I just think in my opinion I think
there's so much more to relationships
than sex like literally like if I
decided to go celibate right now I
wouldn't feel any type of way so I don't
think how many people somewhere for
women they're women yeah men are
different if you told a guy oh you get a
wife
if you get a tell a guy you get a wife
but no sex no guy is gonna sign up for
them
you know I think you tell yourself
you're different but I think it's
literally just about self-control
um yeah and just learning how to just
control yourself and just not be a dog
like you can't just talk no you can't
just say oh men are different that's why
I'm allowed to sleep with 100 people but
I want a virgin you can't say oh yeah I
never said like anyone's allowed to do
anything
um but or you know I mean people can do
whatever they want but the part I'm
trying to make is like like we are
definitely different
um from what I've read it seems like
testosterone is a primary hormone that
determines the one's libido so men have
that a lot more so that it would make
sense that alibito generally is a lot
higher and I'm not saying this is
exhausted for all men and women I'm just
saying generally men have a higher
libido and they're for a higher sex
drive so that difference is a fact well
and it's not about what they can and
can't do like a lot of times people try
to make this like men can sleep with a
lot of people and women can't as a moral
argument but it's just how it's always
been throughout all of history women
have typically been virgins and if they
were not virgins they were concubines
and the man would get multiple women or
at least the top man anyway like the top
like 15 percent of men most men were
monogamous in history but the top men
just had a lot of women
yeah I think being societally allowed to
do something as well doesn't necessarily
mean a lot of guys can just gives you a
society societally allowed to that
doesn't mean your state is here are a
bunch of other things allow you to
actually get that get that result I was
looking for
gosh I'm trying to find this study where
it talks about like what percent of men
will ask a girl their body count I've
never asked no it's higher than you
think yeah because I just don't think
you're gonna get it right on so I just
like watch you know because then you can
actually see you know I would never I'd
rather like watch paint dry on the wall
than ask I think asking it just it's
just it's just not going to be worth it
bro because you know you're not
necessarily going to get the true
exactly some kind of weird amalgamation
of the truth of their life wow very well
said
can't find it but it's roughly like 50
percent of mental ask in the first like
three months basically like yeah 15 and
it's like over like
seven to ten or something roughly most
men will disqualify you if you've slept
with more than that facts yeah yeah yeah
because that's because it's just like it
just it's not that it's the high body
count is usually a symptom of something
else
that's not conducive to a long-term
relationship that's the big thing it's
like the decision-making factors that
have led her to be like you know in her
20s with like 30 40 bodies you're just
like okay uh
well what happened what do you guys what
do you guys think the average body count
is for a 30 year old single woman
because the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31. so let's just
say he meets her at 30 what's the
average body count of a 30 year old
I think that's that's difficult to say
because like obviously you work in a
particular industry and your lifestyle
is a particular way so you're going to
be influenced by what's around you I
mean they're definitely women on all
sorts of spectrums in terms of numbers
like
I would say definitely hiding in the
past
um yeah yeah given uh that's that's a
really tough one I mean it could be a
Broadway and just say maybe like
40 to 60. cool and that's like I guess
like being kind of polite especially
because of how accessible it is it's
like the average body count according to
data is four to eight who believes that
is happening so bad does anyone here
believe that
this is why you don't ask for their body
counts
maybe if they're nuns or they're in a
church
maybe but as far as average ladies go I
don't think so not unless they really
are done with Jesus Christ
do you think that's because we're in
London though oh sorry because
it might be a bit different if you're in
the countryside a little bit more I I
think I think it'd be higher if it's in
a Countryside because there's nothing
for them cats to do out there
I think it's the opposite all the all
the good girls that I met they all live
like in the [__] sticks oh you need
to watch Emmerdale I think because like
the city is like I don't know modern
cities are just like giant hookup
cultures centers yeah you know nobody
comes to the cities like I'm ready to be
a good girl in the city girls don't like
go to Miami like I'm really ready to
find a good church down there
you know
and uh I I think you know I think it is
an important question for guys because
it's like that's a slang now everybody
you say what is body count like I was
explaining body count to my mom she's
like have these people killed people
why would somebody talk about a body
count like that I was like no mom
actually it's this part of the culture
but I think yeah I mean for guys
I've been alone I've been all over the
world I've been in Africa I've been all
over Asia I've been South America you
know Canada North America Europe and it
seems across the board that guys do
value a woman with a lower body count
versus a higher body count and I just
think I think more guys are concerned
with it but they I think they either
kind of give up like uh uh the gentleman
over here just said like he's like ah
this they're gonna lie so [__] it
um but I think like certain other guys
did they just want to know the truth for
me I just want to know what I'm getting
into that's I met a girl one time she
was like yeah I went on like I had a
whole phase on the first date she told
me and I was just like yeah I really
respected her for telling me that then
we had sex at first date
what about you guys what do you think
the average body count is for a 30 year
old woman in the UK
just here London in London
um
likely to be honest because I don't I
mean um your friends don't you yeah but
my friends are kind of married and you
know that they got married very early on
um so yeah
um
I'm just gonna pick a number I'm just
gonna say 15. 15. yeah okay what do you
think like four five four or five yeah
okay by the time they're 30. oh first
like six seven I don't know you know you
know how many years 30 years is yeah but
like I don't know like let's say now you
lose your virginity when you're like 16
that's one person and then when you're
and then you're in a relationship with
that person so you're 22 and then you
meet another person like it
like six seven
I mean yeah I guess it depends on the
kind of kind of it depends on the kind
of person that you have really but are
they saying 45 120 in the chat
more accurate than yeah yeah she was
scared to say 50.
hey what do you think
me yeah how many
um
blood clot okay so if they are starting
from the age of 16
um legal age
I'm saying well if we're talking about
in today's climate it could it it's
possible that it could be more than 20
because you've got you know the date and
apps you know all these clubs you know
the fact that Society is actually making
it more
normal for women to be liberated and
empowered by Sleeping with people so
um it could be anything 20 plus
20 plus yeah so 25
30. oh it's not something like that yeah
okay yeah all right what do you think
uh I would say definitely 20 plus
if she's been give me give me a number
that you think it's at
um
let's see
25 25
they did a study with mattresses that
were like is an indirect study that they
like figured out body count that way and
they said it like from 28 29 30. it's
like according to this mattress study it
was like 40 to 50. wait how do they how
uh it was something to do with like
something about the mattress and like
DNA left of the mattress and wear and
tear that's so crazy or like and buying
new mattresses and the reasons why and
yeah you should check it out to check
out the with the mattress study the mat
I'm right look what about you what do
you think it is
around about the 10 Mark based on
um you sang earlier men sort of their
cut-off points about 10 okay so and I'm
gonna assume that these men
um
very average normal thinking men so no
this is for women for women yeah so if
um yeah 10 10ish because if a man at 30
is going my cutoff point for a woman is
10.
I think that man
tried to be
open so you can get a man that's like oh
I don't want anyone
um
that slept with even one person that's
a smaller group of men and then the
other way as well the men that I don't
mind what number it is it could be 40 50
it doesn't make a difference and that's
the Other Extreme but I think if the
average man is saying about 10 and
that's their Mark then I think women
for me anyways about the 10 Mark I would
say by and large like women don't
necessarily prioritize what a man wants
a long-term relationship women will sip
around exclusively despite men nowadays
just because they don't want to do that
yeah they'll F his best friend right
second song lyrics yeah yeah and then
like when you have like Instagram and
stuff like kind of forcing girls to like
sexualize himself for more likes and
more views and stuff like that it's
everywhere like we live in the most
hyper-sexualized time humans have ever
had why do you guys think all of the
guys had higher answers than the women
per what they thought the average body
count is
well they just said that they like they
won't believe us right if we say any
number so I guess you know what what
happens at um a e is when you walk in
and you say that I don't know you've
been throwing up because you're too
drunk they'll ask you how many drinks
have you had and if you say three
they're going to say okay so you've had
nine drinks they're not going to say
that to your face but they're going to
assume that you've had you know
far more drinks far more drinks than
you're saying because you could be lying
because you could be scared so I think
it's the same type of thing here where
if we'll say Okay 15 so they're gonna be
like okay yeah that's about it it's very
type of thing but why do they think that
um
so like why do you think that like why
do you think the men think we're lying
or at least guys why do you think we're
lying experience I would say
yeah but what do you mean I'm so
confused how did you find out these
girls are lying about their body count
like what made you know you can see
through that action what's an example of
when you actually were like because when
you lie the only thing you can keep that
lie going with is more lies and
eventually
noticing holes in the story I dated this
guy should I dated this guy for three
months and then you're like then I was
single for this whole time and then
later she's like oh yeah I went here
with this guy on vacation and like
during that Gap period where she was
supposed to be single like we were going
on vacations with a guy you know okay so
you put the dots together I don't even
try to put the dots together but I'm
just I'm human and I'm just like wait a
minute because if you if you're dating a
girl you listen to what she says right
because if you're not you're just
[__] her leaving right so if you're
actually dating a girl you care about
her to a degree so you listen to what
she says and then with your general
listening skills you're gonna start
noticing inconsistencies in her story
and you're like okay either she's dumb
or they are some lies happening here so
with every single person that's told you
that body that's happened like you've
ended up catching them out on a line
well there's other things as well like
um General mannerisms around men there's
a certain level of comfort that you
don't want your girl to have around
certain guys and stuff like that do you
want to say you want your girl to be
still a little bit more modest and
demure you know what I'm saying so she
knows she has a certain level of respect
for herself that level of respect is
transferable that so when a woman has
that much respect for herself it
transfers onto you and to the other
people that she's around when she's a
little bit too anxious to get into a
conversation with certain men and stuff
like that not like not saying hey when
when I'm talking women shouldn't be
there and stuff like that but you know
what I'm saying there's a certain
familiar rather familiarity
uncomfortableness that you just don't
want someone that's supposed to be your
wife to have him so does that equate to
body count yeah because she's obviously
used to dealing with mandam and being
familiar when she's got the banter when
she knows the bouncer stop that but I
don't think that really
for example I'm
I'm a friendly person like I'm very it's
not necessarily friendly you know what
I'm saying it's not necessarily friendly
um everybody wants to date someone
that's friendly nobody wants to date a
wolf around them things there but you
know what I'm saying when it's a kind of
vibe like a a do you know what I'm
saying you're a little bit too
you're a little bit too comfortable
chilling with Amanda yeah or when she
starts doing certain things in bed
you're like wait a minute where did you
land this is you know because when
you're when you sleep with a girl who
doesn't have a high body count you see a
girl who does yeah the performance is
it's not totally the one guy that shows
with could have just taught her he could
have but like there's enough yeah like
it could it could be that but also you
know it could also be that she has a lot
of experience and more women now let's
be honest I would say I would bet my
life that the majority women are lying
about their body counts oh yeah 500 for
sure to answer your question then I feel
like the reason why men probably think
that our body counts are higher not I
don't know what the word is I don't
think it's an insecurity but I think
it's like men just have this little like
this little burning hatred
we do have fragile it goes wait wait
that's the word
did you say they have a hatred for women
he's got the right word go it's like
this kind of like ego like I don't know
like like you you I think women are
bigger egos than men do you think yeah
you can criticize a man and he'll take
it and improve where women will just
[__] and moan whoa like if you tell a
guy you're fat he'll work out if you
tell a woman you're fat she'll whine and
make a whole movement called body
positivity
if I can say something
um so I think it's kind of men are very
intuitive in a sense where they will
subconsciously look at your actions the
way you carry yourself as a woman can
tell them a lot about you okay so the
way you speak the way you present
yourself to the world the way you dress
and I'm not talking about or you can't
wear this or whatever it's just how you
walk how you talk your mannerisms your
um your um you know how your hand
gestures your um how you're trying to
you know how you articulate yourself to
the world
um how you are with his friends how you
are with people that are serving you the
restaurant how you are with your family
or on the final genuinely how you behave
as a woman can tell men a lot about you
um as a person and you know how how many
men possibly could have slept with you
know are you extremely extroverted and
aren't loud and you know upbeat and you
know you you open your mouth to everyone
and you're you're very you know just
yeah extroverted that could possibly
mean that you're you know more likely to
be partying maybe maybe see people with
more people I think we got two options
here okay this is why I think there's
some confusion because the men are like
you guys are sleeping around with this
many people and the women are like no
we're not it's less either the men are
lying about sleeping us or the women are
lying about who they're sleeping with
well I mean it would make sense for
women to lie about her body count
because I think deep down they know like
they all know yeah and you know what's
interesting it is an insecurity but it's
a biological insecurity it's like it's a
valid
I mean it's an insecurity it's a bad
investment it's like if you had somebody
who showed up to your place and they had
a resume and they're like I worked here
for three months I worked here for one
month here I worked for two weeks this
guy I worked for this guy for one night
you know you look at this resume you're
like I don't know if this is so bad I
couldn't I couldn't keep a job
I think it's an insecurity in the sense
that insecurity is always inversely
proportional to value and men obviously
value Purity and you know what I mean so
it's not it's like it's like if you
haven't eaten in about six seven hours
you're gonna get very insecure about
where your next meal is coming from it's
like that kind of biological insecurity
that makes sense yeah you absolutely
should be insecure about and nowadays
too like modern women they'll anytime a
guy has a preference you're like oh he's
just insecure he can't handle you know
my high body count he can't handle my
insufferable personality you know it's
like saying I like that girl the other
night who is like arguing and being
really nasty and she was saying she was
a virgin when you are not acting like a
virgin
yeah it's like saying a woman can't
handle a guy who's a loser no that's hat
oh my gosh that's crazy this girl did
this whole show she did a whole show
talking about she doesn't date the bad
boy anymore she only dates nice guys
right only the nice guys when she's done
with that and it's crazy because after
the show someone brought their friend
and I didn't know the guy well like he
was just like like I think one of our
recruiters brought him or something and
this guy was
um a rapper who'd been to jail
and she went home with him
I mean I don't know I I don't know the
guy well at all I just can't imagine you
know yeah I mean but but I am going to
play devil's advocate for for today do
men lie about hooking up with a girl
when they didn't
um
I don't see why you would I guess some
guys do but I just don't see the point
like I mean they're definitely guys who
do but that's just like lower value
Behavior than like why would you have to
lie about that sort of stuff I don't
even like speak about that kind of stuff
if you want to keep it on the hush have
you ever found a guy lying about that uh
yeah I mean maybe like yeah maybe like I
don't know somewhere
in high school you're younger but no one
you actually chill with no no one in
your circle would do that yeah because
if you get found out your boy's gonna
rip you up
let's be honest to tell the chief I
could understand I understand this
question and how it correlates to women
lying about
um their partners and stuff but here's
the thing in a way it's almost
understandable for women to lie about
their body count because at the end of
the day they have to repackage their
past and sell it to some guy in the
future do you know what I'm saying that
that's the whole thing is like literally
I was talking with one of my friends
like this past week
ago I was dating um a year ago because
of my routine and stuff like that my
schedule I never really have time to go
on dates so she just ubered me to her
house
um for stuff and then
um we had a cool relationship whatever
it was and we don't talk no more but I
saw her with online with this other guy
and she looks like she's presenting
herself as the wifey type they're going
on dinners and whatnot and I was scared
for him because I didn't have to put in
any of that work to get something from
her so Dad just made me understand that
when it comes a certain time comes in a
woman's life to us like okay I have to
repackage my past and just sell what I
have now to the highest bidder so you
can't let
the guy know that yeah I was ubering
guys to my house when do you know what
I'm saying not when you want him to give
you dinner and steak and all that good
stuff so it's a catch 22. this video
catch 22. so I'm curious from the guys
have you ever hooked up with a girl
after she'd come from a date with
someone else definitely yeah
definitely why are you are you smiling
have you ever done that
I'm just surprised that people do that I
mean yeah you'd be surprised man
you'd be surprised do you guys know any
girls that have done that
most probably
no no
they're Mother Teresa they're nice women
they don't have any bad friends or
nothing
so who do you think
you think body count
average chicks cute chicks or hot chicks
[Music]
I'll take average
that's the average why why debate
because
um it's just gonna like for men the the
bar for entry is lower you know so you
don't have to do as much to
um entertain them
and because those girls definitely
aren't used to again the influx of
attention that ladies on the higher end
of this year you don't think average
chicks get a ton of attention
a ton of attention but it might not be
it might not be from a certain quality
of man you know so so for eight goes and
talks to a five she's gonna be
immediately more receptive where if her
eight goes and talks to an eight that
the Mountain's gonna still have to work
because that lady knows she's a name
because she's used to life as an eight
you know I'm saying life has told her
that she's innate you know so when life
tells a lady that she's a five she knows
that she kind of has to work with that
so
yeah Gotta Give it up sooner
yeah
look anytime you hear these like
nightmare body count stories too these
girls confessing it on Tick Tock they're
always like mid-looking girls yeah it's
you'd never see like a gorgeous girl
being like yeah I have like a hundred
body count you know it's always these
mid girls and I think it's because
there's kind of an insecurity there
about her looks and so in order to get a
guy sooner she gives it up sooner to get
the validation
yeah because I mean I just would assume
just because you're getting obviously so
many options if you're a hot girl it's
like most dudes are cowards too most
guys will look at most guys will look at
a really hot girl and look at an average
girl and be like ah I'll just go for the
average girl because
you're not an average guy no I'm very
flat it's true most I would say most
guys are intimidated by beautiful women
absolutely you know okay yeah do you
know I would actually switch based off
that reasoning because it does make
sense
what what do you guys think
I mean I've got I've got an example I
mean I have a friend
um he's a photographer and his body
count is just a random conversation he
said it's it's above a hundred so I mean
okay fine you know it's yeah but at the
same time yeah he he did say that you
know if he doesn't have a girlfriend at
a time he will have at least five really
average girls that are going to jump on
it just like that so yeah so average
what do you think
um I don't really have an opinion on
that question I guess average I don't
know average what do you think it makes
sense what the boys are saying yeah yeah
for average so I was just I was trying
to find the mattress thing and I found
like an ask for advice type thing you
know so we're gonna has a panel
give this person advice all right yeah
yes
is sleeping with 11 guys at 17 too many
yes I'm 17. wait wait wait wait I'm 17
and I've slept with 11 guys some of them
have been my exes and some just friends
and one time things my first time was at
15 and I've never thought that body
count matters but a few days ago one of
my exes texted me and he found out that
I was friends with his current
girlfriend and he was so angry at this
he called me a [__] and an [__] and
something
asks like it's got a swear thing over it
and Chuck and how convenient it was how
convenient for him it was that I'm such
a honestly I laughed it off at first but
that night and every night sense all
I've been doing is thinking about what
he said and crying myself to sleep at
night I just need the honest truth is
that too many guys
it is yeah definitely for a lot of guys
it is too many guys the the first do you
know who the top comment is
aren't you scared of an STD
what would your advice be to a girl that
did that
go to church
I'll just say chill out I think younger
women need to remember the fact that um
I mean it's your choice and you know
we're not your parents but at the same
time you need to remember about the fact
that sex is not just
um you know pleasure uh something fun to
do it's actually quite uh important to
remember that you have something like
oxytocin which helps you bond with your
partner
um you know when you get married and you
know it does better for the children and
the household later on and it's it's
actually very very uh biological very
scientifical in a sense and you need to
really look into that and see that you
are losing this and the ability to bond
with a man and then later on create that
safe environment for children for
yourself as a woman as well if you sleep
with too many guys you know and I think
they they really young women should
should really get know that fact because
it's it's literally jarring like I look
at it sometimes I look at stories online
and it's just
you know
yeah guys read those same stories that's
why we think all girls are hoes even
though they're not you know what I mean
yeah so that that's just that's just
what would you tell her to do
fine Jesus what would you would you tell
her to be celibate yeah I don't
understand why people are just so like
have this sexual compulsion like you are
you just so horny all the time that you
just need to go out there and
just give yourself to the world I don't
get it
so what she should be celibate for how
long like what so she's 17 let's say she
wants she wants to get married I'd say
just get like I don't know does she have
a boyfriend like they just get a
boyfriend and like try to keep it to
like one person like if you really need
to or maybe you know you could have an
issue as well you know like sexual issue
maybe go to you know check it out maybe
have you know higher demand for it for
some reason maybe your testosterone
levels are higher you know it's like it
could be anything but I I think you get
a boyfriend and just like keep it to
like one person so you say get a
boyfriend yeah
what about you MLD
uh I find Jesus just find Jesus find
Allah like whichever religion will take
you because you you need God in your
life you know but it's just hard it is
hard like I don't know I think it's an I
think you know it's sad to say this dope
but uh it's it's kind of like a joke to
talk about daddy issues but I think a
lot of these girls that in my experience
a lot of these girls that sleep around a
lot they're looking for that male love
that their father never gave them and
like and if they put like a sexual spin
on it and then you know they're looking
for this love that they can't get
from man in sexual partners yeah my
question for this is where were your
parents yeah exactly you know what I
mean like my parents would not like
there's no way like where like I just
don't even know how would you hook up
with 11 guys do your parents not know
where you are yeah most of the times
it's broken households you know you know
what's crazy I knew someone in high
school her mom let her bring guys over
wow how crazy is that single mom or a
married mom divorced mom there you go
okay here's the answer that ain't
letting that happen because Dad knows
what's going going on in that guy's life
yeah yeah keep that door open I went
terrify every guy if I have daughter oh
my gosh yep can I say something
[Music]
17 she's literally just became legal to
have sex and none of my friends have
been like that but people that I've
known that I've had like a lot of sex
work when they're young
um it's mostly because because of like
maybe they've been
what's the word winner guys
what's the word when the guy's trying to
influence you to have sex with them
persuade seduce
[Music]
were they being groomed not groomed but
I feel like I feel like we need to look
into like why that's happening how old
the um guys women are horny yeah yeah
yeah you know it's actually 17. yeah but
we have songs like wow yeah okay but but
it's like if a guy Robs a Bank at 17 he
goes to jail like I don't understand
this idea that somehow we don't know
what we're doing in my opinion I just
think when you said wherever her parents
I do think that's true I just generally
think that she needs a female figure or
just someone there that's able to talk
to her and able to make her understand
the dangers and what she's doing
um and also looking at looking at the
guys that she's sleeping with could they
can't all be 17 like some of them could
be overaged some of them could be
influencing her right but the common
denominator is her not that yeah exactly
like seven she's going out there she's
not like like walking out the front door
I'm like oops I slipped and fell exactly
it's consensual she's looking for it
she's not the wisest she's ever gonna be
at 17.
someone there like to help her I
understand what you guys saying it's 100
her fault it's 100 her problem but if a
17 year old generally came up to me and
said my body count is 11 instead of just
straight away judging her I would really
try and sit down with her and try and
understand like what the hell is going
on because she probably doesn't have
someone there around her somebody
doesn't have a parental figure yeah
that's what I was saying earlier that
it's like it's uh it's a symptom of
something else yeah like you know yeah
but it's interesting because it's like
we don't usually have the same sympathy
for guys in this situation like if a guy
you know commits a crime at 17. I don't
really see the same sympathy we have for
a girl that sleeps around at 17. that's
true I would feel the same sympathy but
I do think that's true I think with men
um because we expect them to be a bit
more switched on and a bit more so that
I mean we wouldn't have the same
sympathy for them so if we expect men to
be a little more switched on why do we
say that women are more mature
damn if we if we assume that the men
have more responsibility
do you know I think it is I think it's
just to stimulate like economic activity
because it's like if you provide that
kind of Liberation you know you like men
are typically harder to Market too so
it's just like you can give you know
women that sort of yeah freedom and then
you know they can make some more money
and then obviously you just you know
Market off that
um one reason why um I've Outfield more
Sympathy for the women as well I think
in terms when it comes to things like
sex women are more vulnerable when it
comes to sex so I think that's why what
do you mean by vulnerable how
um right more likely to get sexually
assaulted more likely
um I don't know what that c word is
there's a word coerced thank you
and I'm more likely to get coerced into
what is coerced so let's say now I'm
sitting with a guy and then he wants to
sleep with me and I keep on saying no
but it's like oh come on come on and I'm
just keep on saying no but he just keeps
on making me feel guilty for not doing
it so I end up sleeping with him because
I'm feeling so you change your mind
you can just leave like the situation
you're not forced to be it's not as easy
as that especially if a guy's making you
well I mean if you're in a public place
right I mean and you know you can be
safe and there'll be some people to
actually be around you like you have to
you have to leave like otherwise it's
your choice unless unless you're saying
it's not consensual but if it's
consensual then you know Authority comes
with responsibility but I'm talking
about from a psychological point if I'm
with a guy and let's say now a guy's
talking about he's talking to dinner at
this couldn't it's not happened to me
personally but let's say now guys took
me to dinner
um and then he brings me back to his
place and then
um now he wants to sleep with me and he
keeps on making me feel guilty by
bringing them things up oh but I took
you to dinner oh but I did this for you
all but I did that for you that's sexual
coercion because it will make you almost
like feel guilty I think you're going to
his place like you know what he wants
you can't just pretend you don't know
what you're understandable but that is
and you set your boundaries basically
women it's understandable but that's
just the difference I think women just
make up words not you but I do think
women we just make up words to absolve
us from anything we do definitely do not
believe in sexual coercion no
no sorry okay you so what would you I
wanna I wanna hear this coercion
situation yeah I mean I just I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell I'm gonna say the
scenario and you can tell me if I'm
wrong but I just want to make sure I
understand it okay so I go on date with
said man right me and said man go back
to his place and what we're we're making
out we're kissing like what because I'd
imagine like there's a build up if he's
he's saying like yeah so um so before I
start that when when it comes up grape
obviously I'm not saying that that this
is what it is but if someone if you're
in the middle of trying to sleep with
someone and the person says no even if
your clothes are off even if you're
fully naked even if you're at the point
where penetration is close if a woman
says no yeah fine cool okay so there's
that part so with sexual coercion if you
go to his house and you start kissing
and then you all of a sudden don't want
to do anything anymore that a lot of the
time men can make you feel guilt if
you're not wanting to do anything well
yeah because that's a shitty thing to do
why did you get naked
resources
what I'm saying is it it's not nice but
at the end of the day what if a guy did
that to you
yeah he's about to sleep with you he's
like yeah never mind
in my experience when she left
self-control when they're like sexually
turned on by a guy then guys do yeah I
was just about to say it's funny that um
to kind of go with Powersports playing
um when ladies do it you you come with a
new term called sexual coercion but when
ladies do it to men it's just called
seduction no it's still sexual coercion
if you don't want to have sex with a
person
that's the problem then then it becomes
dictated by her feelings which can
change yeah but what I'm trying to say
is driving sex at any moment your
feelings are 100 Allowed no nobody is
saying that they can't yeah and you said
it it is annoying it's really annoying
if all your clothes are off and then the
person just all of a sudden says no I
don't it is annoying but at the end of
the day if the person said no the person
but we're talking about coercion I just
I think that word is a word that women
made up to just take accountability off
of them right because accountability of
what of being responsible for any
decision they make so like I I don't
think he coerced you if you changed your
mind because he's persuasive
you know what I mean if I if a guy says
no and then I persuade him to have sex I
didn't coerce him but it's less of
persuasion it's more of like obviously
it's persuasion but it's like you don't
want to but you feel almost forced into
doing it for example if your friend
tells you oh let's go out to a party
today this is it's still coercion just
not in a sexual sense if your friend's
like it's still questionable you could
just say no like it's a very powerful
way
I mean like coercion so if you if you
want to go to outdoor party and your
friends like oh let's go out to this
party and they keep on trying to force
you to go to the party and you end up
going to the party but you're not
feeling it you don't really know but you
ended up going to the party
I have been forced by every sales person
that's ever gotten amazing the stupid
amount of money you know the thing is
you're probably
um from what I can see probably a more
stronger minded person and you'll be
able to say no there's so many women
there's so many women that find it
difficult you say no but do you know how
you become stronger is by starting to
say no no but she's right what she's
saying that's right though yeah in a
sexual coercion isn't real then how come
there'll be times where
um this is just a made-up thing a 16
year old having sex with a 27 year old
that didn't just happen it would have
happened with coercion do you get what
I'm saying I know what you mean I think
it's a 16 year old
there's cases where the 27 year old has
coerced the 16 year old into having sex
with them that has happened yeah that's
something I'm saying so I see what
you're saying and I would say the answer
to that question it's still on the woman
to not put herself in those situations
because because that's the thing because
sex is a very vulnerable thing I mean
you're literally naked yeah at least the
way I do it and
so you know you have to be
smart as a woman you know especially
with every woman saying like you know
I'm an independent woman and we have the
same rights as men then sure then you
have to have the same responsibilities
as men too like I don't walk into the
most ghetto area of Miami walking with
my jewelry flashing around like well you
guys should just respect me like you
know it's just a bad thing to do because
there's a there's a chance that things
can go south so you don't want to put
yourself in these situations where
caution could happen so if you're not
ready a hundred percent to go all the
way then you probably should stay out of
his house yeah exactly because I've been
with girls and I'm like let's go back to
mouth she's like no I know what you're
up to and that was it I blocked her
right after that
I don't know
but it's like
I've got to say I got a bounce
unfortunately okay yeah yeah okay
yeah thanks for coming no that's right
um but it's um it's like women want the
attention from the men but they don't
want to give up sex but it's like then
stop accepting the attention stop going
back to his house stop flirting with
like because usually I'm just imagine
like if there's probably a build up it's
not just like he wants to have sex yeah
I understand what you're saying but also
I feel like with a lot of women I said
is it um seems It's insecure it's like a
lot of women do feel insecure so when a
man gives them attention as you guys
said before when a man gives them
attention or when a man's flirting with
them they feel like they almost have to
like accept that because that no they do
not they don't they don't if you ugly
they do not they were not the girl
okay are any girls going back to the
house of a man they find ugly
no yeah come on
me and it's like I just think it's like
okay
we're equals now right women are saying
we're equals so be equal so do you just
completely not accept that coercion is a
thing that happens no I I don't think I
don't think it's worse like I said with
the thing with a 16 year old and a 27
year old with every single situation
where something like that has happened
well we're we're switching the the word
there because the issue with that was
she's underage so like that like that's
a different thing but when it comes to
them having sex I think someone can
persuade you to but like coercion it
makes it sound like a crime it is it is
it's a form of like
yeah but this is like brainwashing this
is what they do like grape used to be
just I I do think you're kind of taking
away from the severity of actual grape
occurring when you say like you broaden
that yeah there's so much to it it is a
broad definition there's so much to it
it's not just someone pinning you down
and there's so much to it so so much
where did you learn that just
conversations with people research and a
lot nearly every single female that I've
spoken to has had an experience of
sexual assault or
grape
so yeah this is literally coming from
yeah what percentage what percent of
those women filed the police report I'm
not sure and I don't know the exact
number but I know that a lot of people
out of the last how many women have told
you that
how many women have said their acid or
grouped
um I would say I don't know the exact
number but I'd say maybe 90 of women
that I have spoken to oh okay so it's so
there's four ways 90 because I'm just
wondering how often do you how often do
you bring up grape is this like a
comment yeah
I've had conversations with you so so
roughly how many friends do you have
roughly
um right now like two but in my life
I've had lots like Okay so let's just
say 10 friends nine out of 10 of them
have been essayed or great out of the
nine nine or ten how many do you know
filed a police report none of them okay
this is the problem is that women can
accuse men of a crime and damage a guy's
reputation with no evidence and they can
just say things and we don't know if
they're telling the truth
and and we can include things like a guy
persuading you to have sex and we're
gonna include it an essay in grape and
paint a really negative picture of a guy
when that's really not the same thing
mm-hmm okay with me I would always
regardless choose to choose I don't
really want to get into detail but I've
had an instance where I've been sexually
assaulted by someone and um there was a
reason the reason why I didn't call the
police at that time is because the area
was that I wasn't supposed to be in that
area anyway
um so I just didn't wanna my mom to know
so like he like took you or what
happened I don't really want to explain
it
what I'm trying to say is so when that
situation happened
um I didn't really want to say anything
at the time because I was scared so I
just told my friends
um told my friends and then they told me
to tell the police but even if I was to
tell the police there's no cameras in
that house there's no evidence there's
nothing it's literally He Said She Said
So then one day I decided you know what
um I'm just gonna take it to Snapchat
and I'm just gonna tell no sorry I
decided I'm gonna call his mom to
explain to his mom what happened so we
can actually try and sort out the issue
I did that his mum shouted me on the
phone and just repeatedly told me rely
on
um I called him when he knew exactly
what happened and exactly
um what she did to me he was denying it
on the phone but it's like that that
wasn't no coercion or anything it was
literally blatant
um and yeah he just denied it so so like
when you say blatant what does that mean
like it was blatant sexual assault like
it wasn't something like rape
no it was just blatant say I don't know
because this is the problem is like we
use these words and I just don't know
what they mean because I don't know when
you say essay is it coercion like I
don't know so with grape it's
penetration so but um
yeah it was just blatant sexual assault
okay yeah I
so how do you how do you how would you
like justice served in the situation so
ideally I would like him to go to jail
but there's no evidence there's no
evidence but if you go to the police as
a zero percent chance of him yeah do you
have people well people have patterns so
it's usually they don't just do it once
so if okay you might not go to the
police for you but if he does it to
three more checks and you guys all go to
the police then they have a case yeah
because it'd be three chicks tell the
same story well at that time it just I
feel like especially when things like
that happen as well you're just too much
in shocks you just go to the police
straight away I was scared because I
wasn't supposed to be in that place
where I was at the time anyway
regardless and I was scared that no one
would believe me and when I ended up
actually exposing him and bringing it
out none of his friends believe me his
friends called me a liar I got abused so
much by his friends and family well yeah
because you should go to the police
you're again it's there's no evidence so
it's just he said she said like why
would they believe you true but even
with the police a lot of the police the
police reports when people say that
they've been grapes don't really get
because there's no evidence it's
literally a Heche he said he said he's
she said but don't don't they have like
a test that they can sample his DNA and
stuff if because that's with sexual
assault that's a lot harder
um but they do but at the same time you
can just say yeah she wanted it even if
you do that yeah she wanted it what can
you say then there's another time I'm
saying
so then what's your solution to this
I don't know like I've had conversations
with people
um I don't know but I just think it's
just so important to just hear the woman
out a lot more instead of
um just having conversations where we're
coming online and saying a lot of women
lie a lot of women do like it's true
that is true but I'm saying that having
conversations like this online doesn't
really help the situation because if
someone like me is watching this it
makes me feel less likely to even want
to report anything or even want to say
anything because I'm scared about the
way people react even me um where I work
there was one girl that came to me
crying a customer
um because a guy went up to her and just
grabbed her bum out of nowhere and she
came to me literally crying
um and she was scared to tell anyone
because she thought people just wouldn't
care she thought that people would just
think why is she coming it's not it's
not that deep
um it's not that big of an issue
obviously we took it very seriously but
I feel like conversations like this will
make people less likely to come forward
I just think like the story you're
saying doesn't like make sense and I'm
just telling you how it sounds because I
don't understand you would call him and
not the police if because why would you
call someone that that did that to you
it's true I don't know it's true I'm not
saying the way I went around it is
correct it's true I should have just
called the police but what I'm saying is
a lot of the time when you call the
police especially because there's no
evidence is he said she said what would
the police do mostly they usually they
would do they would do a an
investigation but most likely would have
got claws he most likely wouldn't be in
prison
at least he would be on their radar and
then they would you know if they were to
do it again which is true then they have
back evidence based upon you yeah you
know then there's going to be a higher
probability to get these kind of animals
off the street yeah which is true I'm
agreeing I should have just gone how did
his friends know
um because I told them well I told
social media so well tip snapshot oh so
you posted it on Snapchat yeah yeah I
don't think you I don't think I should
have done that either I'm literally not
saying anything I did is right but what
I'm just saying is conversations like
this stop women from wanting like for
example you're saying go to the police
they're the kind of conversation we
should be having stop going to social
media go to the police if something like
this they're the kind of conversation
that I feel like we should be happy when
we're talking about something as
sensitive as sexual assault or grape
instead of having conversation where
we're calling women liar because what
percentage of women really LIE there's a
lot of high percentage that doesn't get
proven but what percentage which means
they don't have evidence what the
problem is they don't even follow
through to see which percent of women
lie because again there's no consequence
and now it's like like men have real
consequences for these type of things
that's why again it has to go back to
evidence is there evidence and I just
think we're in a dangerous place if we
don't warn men to be cautious around
women because women have a lot of power
yeah that's true because that doesn't
even have to be evidence for that to
actually be damaged to a man's career or
reputation do you know what I'm saying
look at Tory Lanez we still don't have
any factual evidence about what went
down between Tory Lanez and Megan good
but Tori's career is over
that's just the way it is and stuff like
that you know what I'm saying fair
enough
um I was having this conversation with
one of my friends as well
um I feel like the reason why a lot of
men think that women lie as well is
because they don't actually know what
sexual assault is or what group is or
for example coercion so if I went to a
man's house and he coerced me into doing
something that I didn't want to do and I
went to one of my friends and I tried to
say and I tried to explain it and then
it ended up getting around he would be
calling me alive because he doesn't
understand what he did is wrong like a
lot of men don't understand as well some
things that you do is blatantly wrong
even the guy at the club when he ended
up touching the girl's bum he just
didn't understand how it's wrong because
he was just like well the issue is
feminists have expanded the definition
of assault and abuse and so it's like
what they do is they literally put
everything in that definition and now we
it doesn't mean anything anymore what's
some examples of sex I mean what you
just said were like sexual assault used
to be a serious crime and now you're
telling me it's a man convincing you to
have sex
but yeah yeah yeah but you said that's
part of sexual assault that's you said
earlier like like grape used to be a guy
taking you but now there's a lot more
now because I feel like we're more
educated on what it is no I think we're
more brainwashed that's my opinion I
think it's like women it's like either
we're equal or we're not equal either we
want to be men or we're not men so like
right now feminists want to be equal so
be equal but like do you think a guy can
go to the police and say oh I was
coerced no do you think a guy can go to
social media and have everybody give him
attention when he says this happened to
him no it's just women like I just think
either we're equal or we're not equal
and like women just have a lot of power
in today's society I know so many men
that have been falsely accused of things
and there are real consequences for
these men so it's like either we're
equal or we're not mm-hmm
but you say they've been falsely accused
what ends up making you realize did the
woman admit that it was false or
um I'll give you an example A lot of
times [__] comes out like for example
that football player where the woman
said she was raped and thank God he had
ring footage of her climbing on top of
him there was another school in the
United States who um a girl called said
this guy was a rapist right and then
what happened was
um they got the security footage of her
um
pulling him back to the dorm her kissing
him in the bar pulling his head in she
said he was a rapist and he still got
kicked out of school a lot of men still
lose their scholarships a lot of men
still lose their jobs it's like we
believe women at all costs I don't think
that I don't think women are being
believed at all I do think it's very
detrimental there's literally a social
media campaign for women yeah literally
it's called believe all women and I
think the reason why they say that is
because a lot of the time were not
believed because people would just
assume that like if if I was to say if
I'm to sit down with my friend and be
like Oh I got sexually assaulted a lot
of people's first answer would be like
oh well what if there's a campaign that
came out that said believe all men oh
that sounds fantastic
I might support it you should be the
name of our mixtape and then so you said
under what context let's flip the
question back on you believe all women
in what context because there have been
documented cases where women I mean that
one girl here in the UK who said she was
graped by a bunch of Asian dudes and she
took a hammer she her name was Ellie she
busted her face open and she went on
this huge thing and these two guys were
locked in prison for a while and it came
out that she
made up the entire thing so do we
believe all women still
I think I think when they sorry okay
you must be oh no no it's coming
I think it's
we can say
be very careful who you choose to
communicate with because it seems like
there's bad women and there's bad men
for sure so I think that can cover
the issues that we're talking about
right now rather than uh it's all
everything's on the woman everything's
on the map yeah so I think it's
everything on the individual and we have
to make our choices and live with them
as well basically judge it by a case by
case basis we look at the information
the facts both the individuals and then
we deduct it from the anything else is
kind of dangerous yeah due process yeah
which they're throwing away nowadays you
know a lot of places you're guilty if
social media says you're guilty you're
guilty we like convince women to be
traumatized by things we shouldn't be
traumatized by I just can't get over
this coercion he convinced you to have
sex okay you take an L like sometimes in
life you take an L I was literally just
listening to all of this and I just I
have an issue understanding if let's say
it doesn't matter if you're a feminist
or not a feminist but this this thing of
uh Think Like a Man and act like a woman
or something like that right
so why don't you just take it into
action why don't you actually do it
where you think okay well a masculine
trait is super assertive so why don't
you be assertive in that situation I
mean fair enough okay so you're in a
room with a guy because he decided to
get attention from him he decided that
you want to go out with him and let him
I don't know pay for your dinner and
then go back home with him so you have
the right to say you know okay well I
don't think this is a good idea I don't
want to have sex with this guy
but the thing is why in that specific
moment would you lose that completely
and just be like oh my God he absolutely
and completely did whatever else you
know um yeah
um just say no and most guys and I
promise you obviously we have cases we
spoke about but most guys would be like
okay I'm sorry are you uncomfortable if
you are that's fine we don't have to do
this but what what so I think you're
misunderstanding what I mean by sexual
coercion so I understand that you could
feel guilty because we spoke enough
about this and I I understand
there's no physical sexual coercion a
lot of the time the woman has said no
that's what I'm trying to say so when um
you're in a room with a guy the woman's
already said no and the man is trying to
convince you okay he's trying hard one
you can call your brother you can call
the police you can say listen please
don't touch me please stop doing this
because I genuinely do not want to have
sex with you you're doing everything to
get out of the situation and and most
women have got intuition so if you go on
a date with someone you can already tell
that this guy is a little bit off and I
have like you have this as a Woman
Within you that femininity that tells
you okay I need to be careful around
this person how would you get naked like
you know you don't even need to be naked
but I've got a question then to have sex
so I've got a question so if if
you gotta be kind of naked yes so if
that's the way I do it
if someone if someone wants to have sex
with you and you've already said no yeah
so you said the word no and that person
is still trying to persuade you to have
sex you get angry you move away You're
assertive no listen and I said no what
about just leaving yeah can you just not
was it normal what I'm trying to say is
I'm not trying to say that a woman
shouldn't do any of them things they're
the kind of things that we should be
talking about but I'm saying that sexual
coercion is a thing because a lot of the
time women don't women don't have that
strength and we can't blame women for
not being assertive now either we're
equal or we're not think we want to be
equal under the law so people each
person is different when each man is
different equal but there's men that are
not dominant there's men that are are
you mute like why can't they say no they
cut yeah but I'm saying women have said
no do their legs don't work can they not
their legs can spread why can't the legs
walk away I know but I just I just
wouldn't I think I get what you're
saying and blaming a victim if a woman
said no and a man's still is really just
fine like you don't understand how scary
men can be a lot of the time if a man is
Really Trying a lot of the women will
just feel scared a lot of women are
vulnerable vulnerable a lot of women are
vulnerable as well so they'll end up
saying yes just out of favor or just
feeling like this is he threatening them
not threatening well some men can but a
lot of women will just do it out of a
statement threatened you
threatened me to have sex yeah because
you just said men some men can threaten
you they can't threaten me that's what
I'm gonna punch you in the face if you
don't take off your top no but a lot of
the time women just feel fear just uh
because you just said that men will
threaten you so how are they threatening
you they could a man's not threatened me
first
so then you can't use that as anecdotal
evidence when you don't have any
experiences
they could also be guilt shipping as
well
quickly so if you guys so before you get
to the situation where you're back at
that house and the sexual coercion
happens when you guys uh having a dinner
or whatnot and a check comes and
everything's unspoken and then he goes
to pay and your ass is quiet
is he being financially coerced right
then and there yes
that is financial coercion no it will be
Financial coercion if he's saying I
don't want to pay and I'm forcing him to
pay you guys are not understanding the
no that's what it starts with it starts
with the no and then you're still trying
to make well well doesn't it it kind of
start with the with the context of the
situation because in the the sexual
coercion situation there's the context
of YouTube being alone being Amorous
before and then the situation you know
everything before then is unspoken and
then it gets to the part where you know
what you're not down with it same thing
in a restaurant you guys are eating you
guys are having a good time then that
[__] check comes so
explain explain the Nuance we need to
know the nuance
yeah I mean then it goes back to just
personal responsibility like because if
you're with if you're a guy and you
think that a girl may not be trustworthy
or she has a history of accusing people
or you know she just seems a little edgy
like you have to understand that like if
you get involved with this girl you know
there could be repercussions as well and
I think a lot of guys calculate that
risk as well I actually think men should
not date and not nothing personal but I
actually think men shouldn't date women
that think coercion is sexual assault
because you don't know what she's gonna
can like say that you did yeah like if
you do not know what yeah you should not
date women like that because that it men
have too much to lose in this Society
yeah I mean if they have any of the
symptoms if he has like pronouns in her
bio like all right uh swipe left on that
one you know there's there's certain
symptoms of women you have to avoid not
well I just don't understand it these
men are so scary like why are you alone
with them yeah if you don't want to do
it like why are you alone with them
before you're married then just don't be
alone with them until you get married
yeah which is true and that's what I'm
saying is true but I think I can
understand a little bit where you're
coming from
in the sense that you might get a
certain
um
let's say
we know that
something like this is more likely to
happen to younger women than older women
we know uh
let's say
women this is now a personal opinion
when you're bringing a child up it's a
little girl
it might not be like this for every
upbringing but
you you say to little girl oh
don't do this for me be a good girl can
you do this for me can you do that for
me
um for me more than the boys mum going
to the boy can you do this for me can
you do that for me so
as the basis I feel like
women get asked can you do
can you take out the trash or can you do
this can you do that and where yes yes I
can do this I can do this really I heard
I don't cook I don't clean
as well but yeah um
that's a lot of women but let's say the
the women were when they were little
girls they had their Mum and Dad going
please can you do this please can you do
that even if you don't want to do it for
me so when she grows up and when she's
like 17 she might meet a guy
that says the same thing do this for me
do that for me and I get it the girl
should know better but when she's had
that all her life and then this feels
kind of like oh it's not that big of a
step from what I've known and then it
happens and then she wakes up the next
day and thinks
all my life I've had this and then this
has happened to me I thought it was okay
it's now not I feel really bad she
shouldn't blame the guy but
look at herself and then make
adjustments through that yeah so I'm
just pulling up the definition of the
word coerce so coerce is to persuade an
unwilling person to do something by
using force or threats so putting those
two words together sexual caution based
upon your definition you are not
sexually coerced okay if it's if it's
Fourth then because that's what the
unless Google's wrong but it says
persuade an unwilling person to do
something by using force or threats so
do you think it's maybe you felt regret
after it or and that's why as I stated
sexual coercion I'm not saying it's
something that's happened to me I'm
talking about in general I think you
just said it happened to you I said
sexual assault has happened to me not
coercion okay an essay
okay what I'm trying to say is it wasn't
grape in in general if a woman has said
no I think that I think anything after
that
you should really be looking at the guy
if if you have said no and the man is
really just trying to force it and
really trying to make like I don't
understand why nobody can see how that's
wrong I don't what you just said is
really interesting I liked what you said
especially when we're growing up as
women
um I think overall like what you were
saying is that a woman grows up to be
assertive like we have to do this we
have to say yes yes Mom I'm saying
whereas there's women that grow up
um who are able to I feel like women
that grow up who are taught how to be
more dominant and are able to say no
would be more better in them situations
but a lot of women are vulnerable a lot
of women don't really know how to say no
in them situations and a lot of guys
take advantage of that a lot of men can
see that when a lot of men take
advantage of weaker women and take them
back to their place why are those women
in the in in dangerous situations
and as I said they shouldn't be in them
situations but they're in it now they're
in it but that's one step is my issue
this is my issue it's like nothing is
ever our fault it's always the men so
you guys know it's always oh poor me I
was convinced to do this where it's like
no you made that choice then don't be
alone
if you you don't have any children do
you no kids no so when you eventually I
make good choices
so when you eventually have a female
daughter and your female daughter God
forbid touchwood but if your female
daughter comes up to you and says
um crying in your arms and says that she
ended up sleeping with some guy she said
no to him multiple times she said no to
my multiple occasions and then she
decided that one and then one day she
went to a party and then they went they
were in a room together and he ended up
obviously you don't believe in coercion
so he ended up um convincing her not
convincing her but just kept on did she
open her legs willingly so even if your
daughter came up to you okay the crying
doesn't matter exactly the facts are the
case
did she open her legs willingly did he
force her or did she open them she would
have done it yeah oh okay well then I
would say well take that out well it's
just fair enough yeah it's and that's
that's like that's like a little that's
like a little bit of uh emotionally
manipulative statement to like a
theoretical thing to make to just try to
prove your point you know because
personal responsibility is personal
responsibility okay no matter what if
somebody if you're in a situation where
you're telling the person no and they're
still pushing that you have to leave the
situation because now that person has
showed you that they are not socially
there like they don't get it so you
gotta leave because that person has
showed you they're now straying from the
social norms and this is not a normal
person and you got to get away from
normal people because that's not okay I
mean you spoke about maturity and like I
think both of you um about like growing
up and stuff and upbringing I'm I'm very
into the upbringing people in general
um because it's kind of what makes you a
person and the person that you are right
now now
um so okay let's say you said women
um I don't want to quote exactly but
women who grew up to be more dominant uh
have it easier they find it easy to say
no right this is just for my brain okay
so that's from so from your opinion yeah
yeah so that's subjective okay so they
find it easy to say no but then okay if
you're from a household where you grew
up to be
um extremely timid as a person and
you're in this situation you found
yourself in a situation wouldn't you
know or wouldn't you be scared in the
beginning
to start with that hold on if I go home
with this guy something like this could
happen yeah and like I yeah but like
I've said already
um if you're in them kind of situations
you shouldn't put yourself in them kind
of situations if you think the guy's a
creep do not go home with the guy if you
think the guy's weird do not go home
with a guy if you don't want to sleep
with the guy but you feel like the guy
would want to sleep with you don't go
home with him I'm agreeing with
absolutely everything that you guys are
saying but what I'm trying to say is
once it's got to that point where a
woman has said no I do not want to sleep
with you and a guy is still trying to
force it despite everything that's
happened the woman still said no and the
guy's a [__] girl she said does she
say no or does she say hahaha no no stop
because you know they're different
I'm I'm just because you know you know
you hear girls that's how they flirt
half the time stop it you've never heard
that no I know what you're saying about
I just I just don't know but just just
what from what I'm saying yeah there's
women that will literally say no or this
is coming from experiences we have
spoken to people those women where they
were literally saying no and the guy was
still carry on and I just really wish
and your mindsets if this is the mindset
you guys want to have it's literally
fair enough but I just really wish that
people could just I don't know I feel
like there will be a man that is
watching this right now he's nodding his
head thinking yeah thinking it's right
but I feel like no we should be saying
that once a woman has said no don't
carry on no no I get what you're saying
yeah we're not what you have to say for
a woman who says no to a guy that's
trying to make certain sexual advances
but then stays in the same situation
with homeboy so she literally has said
no she's made it clear that she's
uncomfortable the guys made it clear
that he's been persistent but she still
continues to be around said guy she
could say no you're making me feel
uncomfortable I'm gonna remove myself
from the situation
yeah and that's true and that's the
message that I feel like like podcasts
especially because you're such like a
powerful person well and I feel like
that's the message you should be
spreading then yeah in these kind of
situations you should be removing
yourself away from it you should be it
shouldn't be something where we blame
the woman but wait wait I want to make I
want to make a quick uh so what are you
trying to tell Pearl her message should
be here on this podcast because not your
message can be whatever no no no because
in this context you just said she is a
powerful podcast so in a perfect world
what would you like her to say and in
regards to the situation if a guy is
hearing the words no you want all guys
to stop
knowledge right nobody said nobody
argued that uh the opposite to that here
I'm saying in general I'm just saying in
general it should be common
knowledgeable right it also because
should be common knowledge for women not
to lie about certain things like who's a
baby daddy and [__] but that still
happens but that's not what we're
talking about but I know I know but but
the you're you're trying to arguing for
a utopian
that right here and it doesn't it
doesn't like I we know nobody has argued
against your point so we don't really
know what you're going on about because
nobody said like yeah she should stay
there and have sex with that guy even
though she said no because she was
leading him down a false the reality a
false belief you know she was misguiding
the guy nobody's saying that so yeah
yeah she's okay because we've been on
this topic for a little bit now we're
kind of going in circles it doesn't I
don't understand what's happening I'm
not able to answer the question so I'm
confused if you're saying nobody
understands what I'm saying what I'm
trying to say is extremely clear I feel
like in situations where if a woman says
no and a man still carries on to try and
persuade that woman to have sex that man
is wrong I feel like this would be more
responsibility on the man to answer your
first question that you said
um to add to that so nobody I want to
clarify nobody said the man was not
wrong okay I'm I'm just point one go
ahead I'm literally just okay anyway
um so to answer his question
um I just generally think that
conversations where we're talking about
um oh so many women lie the the I think
it's very detrimental for women that are
watching this that that will be watching
it because so no no no keep going keep
going no just saying I just think it's
just detrimental when there's just
constant conversations about women lying
about this women lying women lying I
think there should be more conversations
which they have a lot of conversations
on it but I just think we should just
really be talking about how these women
could protect themselves or yeah I think
that we would stop having conversations
about women lying if women lied less
excellent yeah I I think we would see
the conversations go down when we stop
seeing story after story after Story
yeah of women lying and you know it's
like when men lies like uh yeah you know
I slept with that girl when a woman
Elijah's like yeah I was getting raped
by a bunch of people over there and I
hit my face under the hammer honestly
message to guys would be to protect
yourself get ring cameras in your entire
apartment get everywhere
um because women do have a lot of power
and they can't say damn near everything
yeah and Tech is starting to catch up
with these women who are lying you know
what I mean they're starting to catch up
with a lot thank God for modern
technology like it's happened it
happened to the guy with an Arizona
Cardinal cheerleader I mean it's
happened so many times where Modern
women have been debunked because here's
another thing too
the average Modern Woman now knows she
can manipulate public perception to a
certain degree to get behind her
on a lie
and there are women out there who are
weaponizing the justice system in a in a
bad way and so I just think that when
we're just constantly saying like it's
blame the men it's the men's Paul
Smith's fault so here's the deal going
back to your your situation where you're
using sexual coercion which you're
saying is physically threatening
physical violence if that situation
happens again it's up to anybody man or
woman if they're in a situation like
that to leave
you know if like a guy pulls out a gun
at a bank and he's like everybody give
me your money like hey man can you just
not do that like you know do you know
what's interesting if we said Modern Men
are losers modern men need to get their
money up modern men need to get more
masculine men don't really complain
about that they just kind of they kind
of will say yeah we do but it's
interesting if you criticize women it's
like now we need to change the
conversation we need to legislate
something I think the media plays a big
part in that
um a similar situation but maybe a bit
more simple is women walking through
parks at night
because in a way I understand why a
woman would want to walk through a park
at night
if you kill someone it's illegal you're
not meant to do it right
she should feel safe walking through
somewhere near where she lives to get to
the place quicker
but the reality of it is
if
if I'm walking through a park and
someone kills me
that's my fault
even though ideally I shouldn't be
killed walking for a park
but the end of the day I've walked
through the park I've gotten killed
that's on me
but when you see these things in the
media
they will play on the this poor woman
got killed at the park
and that feeds people to think yeah poor
women get killed at the pot no one's the
media is not going you know this woman
should really think about where she
should walk or less educate women when
it's dark don't walk through the park
yeah I've been saying this too no I've
been saying this too because every time
I come to the West it seems that you
know they're just trying to put more
accountability on men and take more
accountability from women I don't know
if you guys agree with me or disagree
definitely but I see that like because
you know there's so many like how many
gigantic men positive social movements
have you seen where name one hashtag
campaign for men
and then go their own way
hashtag I'm surprised you know that so
so that's not a mainstream though that
was men who made it their own but then
all these other ones that have been
engineered by these corporations and
these social media where's the one for
men where's the one like hashtag
paternity rights for men
change divorce lights but I feel like a
lot of these movements that are made for
women empowerment or like women or
whatever I've been made by women so I
feel like if men really feel like in
their guts like why don't we have one a
man should just make one it's not men
that are making these movements for
women
whenever men we do try and give our
points and stuff like that we're
demonalized like someone like Kevin
Samuels and stuff wasn't exactly coming
out here being rude or trying to be
offensive but some some of the things he
said run Rob some people the wrong way
and then we had a ton of people talking
about him like he's Hitler or something
well I mean men tried and you he's in
jail Andrew Tate oh my God yeah yeah
like that's what happens when men try to
do their own movement it's like the red
pill I would say is the closest thing
there is to a men's movement
it's like uh the sector of YouTube that
yeah I see she doesn't even know she's
like
but it's like demonized to be honest
they call everyone in the red pill
misogynistic they say they hate women
when it's really just like more pro-man
by the way
um I do need to go because it is a bit
late but I would like to say it was so
lovely to speak to every single one of
you guys and it was really lovely to
meet you yeah nice to meet you but yeah
and it's got It's really late
yeah just take off your headphones
you're fine you're fine
yeah thanks for coming
is that uh you left your phone
yeah here you go
what are we talking about oh the red
pill it really is demonized though it's
like any time can anybody name a like a
social media company or a government
that has come up with like a hashtag
campaign for men I'm being real has any
is there I'm not aware of any
where's body positivity for men but
who's the little who's the largest
voting block okay Pride I mean like like
that sort of thing so that's not meant
that's not men's Centric that's all
that's a decent answer though
okay I can't actually remember the name
but there was something to do with um
like men and like
um you know suicide type of thing that
this homicide awareness or something a
higher percentage of men that commits
suicide and stuff I think I think there
was but yeah that want more rights for
their children you know that yeah dress
up in
um fancy dress and they climb buildings
and they try to make a point about men
having more rights for children maybe
not so much the the last few years but
in the last 10 years I can say so we
have to sit around here and dig and dig
and be like hey do you remember that
wine like kind of movement that was
maybe led by men but then what do you
have you have a hashtag believe all
women hashtag me too I mean you know
every time like how many women
empowerments groups are there how many
hashtag boss babe what do you hear like
boss dude is that like boss man like
where's the boss man movement right what
Andrew Tate started one and he's in
prison you know like there there isn't
so I don't I don't think it is
disingenuous to look at there's a
gigantic imbalance and again it goes
back to like who are the ones that use
social media most women women who are
the ones that are the largest part of
the voting block women who spends the
most of the consumer money women who
spends the most amount of uh College
loan debts in the United States America
women you know so when you look at the
whole picture it does seem like it's
just a disingenuous manipulation I'm not
saying that bad things don't happen
women from men certainly do but there's
also bad things that happen to men from
women we're just choosing to highlight
and demonize men in the west and if you
look at the culture look at these young
men that are so disenfranchised a lot of
these men are checking out and then now
what do you have women's think where
have all the good men gone
imagine a fat man went on social media
and said I'm a 10. that'd be real they
get the following that lizzo has
test holiday I think there would be a
group of people that would be like yeah
actually you know what I'm going to
support it I don't think it'd be you
don't think the last man who was big and
he said and like he made a big deal of
himself was the Notorious B.I.G and that
was he had to have a huge corporate
label behind him to sell his music for
him I don't think the average fact I
could get up and be like yeah check me
out I'm big yeah that's what I'm saying
a big guy a big guy has to have talent
and Puff Daddy behind him to get noticed
you think about how we have small
Dick Energy but we don't have small tit
energy
[Laughter]
short man syndrome but there's no tall
woman syndrome
yeah show a woman syndrome there's a lot
of Karen's though that's gone up in the
last few years yeah yeah shout outs to
the coast yeah I'm actually a
self-proclaimed Karen
yeah yeah I know I know some people use
this in a different term but I'm just
the type I will complain if the food's
bad and that's a bit you know kareny you
know I don't think but that's not
unnecessary because you speak sense you
know and yeah if most of the time does
Big Time yeah I think they are they are
delusion there's a British Karen that
came over to this guy was like yelling
at him because he was just sitting there
in his car and she's like you're just
sitting here in your car idling
polluting the Earth and he's like man
this is a Tesla and she's like I don't
believe you I don't believe you you know
yeah I just mean like we always use a
Karen when someone called the police on
a party
but I would call the police on a party
yeah I definitely would if it was too
late yeah in the U.S we can do that
anyway I don't know if you guys can do
that here they do that in Japan all the
time yeah all the time no fun
um no but it's really interesting how I
just feel like we've come up with all
these terms in society that just take
accountability off of women even when
you think of like knocked up like who
knocked you up like he did it yeah yeah
it's weird when you think about it
um okay oh I wanted to read this thing I
saw I tweeted this one of my followers
sent this to me on Twitter
um and I said what is a woman
oh that no no it's a different answer
well unless you follow me on Twitter you
might have seen it and a woman is an
adult female virgin
a married female adult
an adult field female nun
everything else is either a man a child
or a [__] oh wow
but it's interesting because I was
thinking about I'm like throughout human
history like most women were virgins on
their wedding day
so it's like by by that standard most
women in modern days are Horrors yeah
like you would have been a concubine
I'm not gonna say anything why not you
can't you can't do you you think this is
offensive do you think this is untrue
um I definitely see how especially in
2023 it can be seen as offensive
um almost as offensive as a man should
still um work his butt off and provide
and be have one of those women women to
choose from as a wife
um but um it's almost bad to say
something like that because I could
understand a ton of people not wanting
to hear that
the um essentially a degenerate for the
way they for their past life choices
do you think is modern relationships
social media okay what do you think MLD
well uh the data shows that the majority
of people terminating relationships are
women
so is it because all these men are bad
yeah maybe it is but then why are these
women choosing bad men
yeah yeah yeah yeah what do you guys
think do you think it's equal 50 50
whose fault
his fault isn't
[Music]
um
I think
it's it's actually become quite
political nowadays
it's all about I mean ever since we've
come up with um
certain movements started being more
much more popular
um you know we've got lgbtq we've got
um all of that I think the left wing
started being much more loud I think and
people started to kind of pay more
attention to it never since we had uh
people who wanted to kind of bring it
down a notch so let's say Andrew Tate
and this is where all of the fights
started happening
and this is what led to men and women
having arguments and you know thinking
you know that the famous what do you
bring to the table and everything is
focused on that right now I think
because of this because of their
political little thing that happened
there you know so it's politics fault
it's whose fault maybe not
but some people I've had people blame
the money money that's a new one I've
heard I've heard the money I've heard
the money broke down the family it's a
new one
I've heard yeah because like when we
went off the gold standard that I forgot
what they said I'm gonna butcher it some
Bitcoin people they basically said when
we went off the gold standard it made it
so like
men couldn't provide anymore because
like all of the currency was getting
inflated yeah because they started
hyperbole do people blame the money
um some may blame the women's right to
vote I'm not going to say I mean that's
like seven so like you need to think
really hard to get to the point of like
relationships from money so I think
that's very very much um you know that's
that's pushed that's like some some say
women some say men maybe the husbands
are evil you know what do you what do
you think if you had to point a finger
I'm not going to point things and I
think the government could be the
government
I'm not going to point finger at anyone
specifically I'm just going to say that
this is what started happening and
that's what happens in the world anyway
it doesn't matter what it is it is um
Collective
um action so something starts happening
on one side and the other and in a kind
of all rolls into like one snowball
um and then things just change so I
think as I said you know previously I
need I need something from you
I need it you could blame social media I
don't know if I can provide but um I
think let's let's just say social media
if you need like a trail bouncer what do
you think
um
on on the statement that you made yeah
whose fault is modern relationships
it's no right or wrong stupid people
okay stupid people yeah
yeah
I gotta blame women sorry guys so
basically the same answer as her though
you know I'm not gonna say that there's
no men that contribute this there are
there are stupid men but I just think
when we look
breaking up the family and its majority
women I I have a hard time not blaming
the women well
um
and the politicians that started to pay
women to leave I do think it's their
fault too yikes
the ladies are getting paid to leave
relationships yeah you didn't know that
yeah yeah so so um I said there's a lot
of incentives from the government to
leave and there's also incentives too I
mean that's why I kind of get on her
about the abuse thing because there's a
lot of government incentives to accuse
guys of abuse oh wow yeah so you get a
free lawyer in the UK If You Accuse a
guy of abuse in in a marriage and it the
rate of men being accused went up 300
percent it's all the stuff she was
talking about it's like feminist
programming it's so weird it's like they
want us to be victims they expand the
definition of abuse so it used to be
just you know you hit me that's abuse
now it's like coercive control Financial
control like they add in all this stuff
to just make women victims and just feel
sorry for ourselves even when she was
talking about earlier when she was
talking about the freaking your daughter
got convinced to have sex okay you take
the L like we used to take L's and move
on now it's we go to social media wine
complain I've been abused it's like
get out of here
yeah like that definitely this is
definitely
um
like trying to decipher who is
um at for for
for the for the fall in relationships is
definitely going to be a slippery slope
and stuff because because men and women
are both involved in both it's it's kind
of hard to be
um
as accurate as we want to be but um so
far unrealistic dating expectations
definitely do seem like just between
normal everyday people and unrealistic
that dates and expectations does seem
like a reason you know what I just
realized it is pretty unrealistic it's
like whenever you blame women for
something it's like the gut reaction is
to let's not but I was like if you blame
men for having a shitty life nobody says
oh don't blame the men yeah what you
said earlier about stupid people I think
there is a I think you know there's a
big stupidity Clause that we're leaving
out because if you look at the Bell
curse it's not wrong no no because if
you look at the bell curve right
literally 50 of people are a hundred IQ
or less
you know and then so this is this is
just based upon what I did some studies
about Japan so in Japan the lowest IQ
and lowest households uh earning
households are in Okinawa and Okinawa is
an island in Japan they have the highest
divorce rate in Japan and then
um fukui prefecture actually has the
highest IQ in Japan and they also have
the lowest divorce rate so it could just
be anecdotal evidence based upon Japan
just multiple factors but I think they
also say the number one reason
relationships go south typically is
because of money and money troubles so I
think you know I think the stupidity
Factor really is a big thing that a lot
of like Intel because I I would assume
everybody everybody here seemed pretty
intelligent tonight it's been a very you
know like balanced conversation so I
think that this stupid quiet factor is
really there because I think what a lot
of people when the guys are like
thinking like damn like you know 78 of
women are initiating divorces you have
to always real you have to realize too
like there's a good portion of those
women and statistically speaking
a large portion of them are factually
idiots you know so you can't really get
too too mad because an idiot's gonna be
an idiot but then it does get a little
tricky because what was the percentage
Pearl on college educated women who
initiate divorces 90 90 so then then
because I don't believe modern education
is an education I believe modern
education is like indoctrination that's
crazy they sat us down in college and
and they convince you of the stuff she
was talking about yeah that's why I
asked her where she learned that stuff
from because in the Obama administration
too that's when they started this whole
thing like one in four women are essayed
on can't I don't think they said great
that was so big when I was in college
yeah it's so big that was great and
because the reason was the federal
government uh under the Obama
Administration said if you guys do not
make these like you know kangaroo courts
which is basically like these
fake quartz fake Justice systems within
the universities and you don't pursue
every one of these cases we're going to
cut the federal funding so that means
they don't get the Pell Grants the Pell
Grant in America is just when the
government will just give you money for
free based upon the FAFSA that you fill
out which is a financial aid thing and
the government loans and when you tie
that into the equation looking at the
only kind of debt that you can't claim
back bankruptcy on in America is student
loan debt you start to follow the money
you look at the government you're like
wait a minute like something is not it
just it it looks very shady you know
what I mean does that make sense
somebody disagree with me if I don't
make any sense I have a question if
feminists say that they don't need a man
then should they be entitled to a man's
protection
[__] around and find out
[Laughter]
I'm definitely gonna be a lot less
enthusiastic about putting my life in
danger to help someone that says they
essentially don't need me to be there
what do you guys think
I mean I think it's just I mean imagine
if guys were running around like I don't
need a woman you know you'd be like shut
up idiot yeah and it's just the same
thing around the other way around like
you're so you're telling me as a
feminist you're just gonna disregard 50
of all life
let me know how that works out for you
because you know everything you want in
this life you're gonna get from a human
and you know some things men do better
than women like how many women are
inventing not many yeah I was gonna say
women women's rights have been equal for
a while but where are they on the
invention Gap are they closing are they
on the The Plum there is a building
being built next door and I am waiting
for all the women to sign up I know I'm
seriously excited I'm just and that's my
issue with feminism it's like
like you want to be equal then be equal
but it's like we only want equality when
it benefits us contextuality yeah it's
like even in the example she was using
about coercion okay be a man nobody's
gonna feel bad for a man if a girl
coerces him into having sex the thing
that was bothering me I think she was
emotionally arguing because the the
definition of the word coercion is you
gotta do this or I'm gonna
threaten you with physical violence and
that's wasn't it that wasn't the case so
in my personal opinion when they start
broadening the the definitions of things
um it's usually just to make more money
because I for example like if you follow
psychology they have something called
the DSM right the dynastic diagnostic
statistical manual for uh mental health
issues and like the dsm-1 was like this
big and then the dsm-2 was this big DSM
four five it just keeps getting bigger
bigger and now you're like oh like what
like what's your mental disease of
choice you're like oh I have this and I
have this and I have this like oh great
well we have this pharmaceutical drug we
have this pharmaceutical drug we have
this pharmaceutical drug right and we're
just they're just doing that to put
people on drugs and the majority of
these drugs like don't get me wrong a
lot of psychiatric drugs do help people
but they're like if you ever seen I
think the commercials are illegal in the
UK right the the prescription drug
commercials so they're in the United
States they're like yeah if you're
depressed take this but side effects
include fatigue sudden death insomnia
diarrhea chronic heart stopping yeah you
know Eastern Europe as well yeah all of
that yeah so it's all again and if you
look at who is like behind a lot of
stuff like I always say anytime you see
some ideological movement or some kind
of big thing put together by the
government or social media just follow
the money and it typically always leads
to money or votes because if the
government really cared about us would
they have locked us down the way they
locked us down in America they kept
alcohols stop shops and marijuana shops
open but they closed the gym so you can
go to church yeah the church as well you
know so and then now I mean how many
people I mean can we can we even say
what happened to certain people that
took a certain thing without the stream
being shut down you know what I mean but
now oh well what was it 15 days to
flatten the curve and in 2021 a little
bit more easily manipulated like they
think the government and these
corporations care about at you and they
don't they literally don't they want to
take your best years they want to divide
the family they want to keep us angry at
each other and it's so unfortunate
because it's literally breaking down the
family because of the policies and the
media that they're pushing well yeah
because the more you know the more um
separated you are the the less powerful
you are the less powerful you are you
have to rely on the government more so
therefore you know this is like the best
outcome do you know how much do you know
the saddest thing so today oh my gosh
craziness happened to me I um I went to
a volleyball did I tell you about this
yes yeah yeah so I went to a volleyball
tournament
um and the the volleyball tournament
there was trans people there literally
pla like there was almost a whole team
in a woman's division five dudes dudes
in there in our locker rooms I swear and
I wasn't even playing I was um I just
went because my friends were there
um and I played in this tournament last
year and the the crazy thing was it was
called All Nations so there's women from
like all these different countries that
come so it's like Poland it's like and
it was interesting interviewing the
women like that agreed with it and
wanted them to play and they would talk
about how their parents were brainwashed
and how their parents had a bet like the
more traditional culture where they were
from was like a bad thing when they had
better results but the thing is the left
thinks that because we have better
technology that we have better outcomes
when technology doesn't replace family
and that's what they're trying to do
I mean even think about like phones
right like how much time do we spend on
our phones versus speaking to our family
yeah yeah it's crazy because you just
get it and then it goes back to again
like the money side of it all like they
they they engineered this thing to be as
addictive as possible no yeah they
literally engineer this thing to be as
addictive as possible so we're all
what's really happening is I think and
then you there was some like some dude
was talking about Rockefellers uh back
in the day and he was just basically
saying like we basically wanted to
separate the family unit because like
when you live in a house together back
in the day like you just had one light
bill one Rent One phone you know
typically one car but if you divide
people and you put them separately now
you can financially extort two different
people at a faster rate because when
people let's be honest like when you're
happy in a relationship you're usually
just eating food at home and having a
lot of sex you're not spending a lot of
money you're not going out too much I
mean you maybe you are but when you're
single you're like I gotta [__] go to
the gym I gotta get a personal trainer I
gotta buy some clothes I gotta do this
I'm doing this wrong because I save more
money when I'm saying
I'm doing this wrong
you know I just think I don't know I
just look at it all from a business and
marketing perspective and I just I just
don't think it's a genuine movement I
think it's disingenuous and I think they
want money in votes you know I really do
um well and I think they use women like
they know women are more easily
manipulated so they convince us that
like they convince us to be victims and
that's why I think it's important to
tell women that we are not victims and
it's okay to rely on a man and it's so
it's okay like and you you can say no in
those situations you're not you're not a
victim and that's just what I cannot
stand is they just convince us that
we're our lives are so hard when
literally we have the best lives we have
ever had in all of human history ever
yeah I think that definitely can I'm
gonna read I'm gonna Read Super chats
for a second
um guys make sure you like the video
okay that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams okay also guys
um I wasn't gonna tell you
blessing wants to get a kick out cam
which we've had such a nice guest today
you know so no no real kick outs anyway
um but but I do think that this is
important that we get one because we've
had a couple kickouts this week and we
couldn't even do it
um okay so pan-african BG matriarch uh
gluttony Doug MPA women are fine with
believe all women until it's their son
or father or brother you don't get to
believe all women when it benefits you
Sydney just want to apologize on behalf
of society we've clearly failed
miserably at raising women now again PA
who coerced her into getting the awful
face tat Rachel Wilson for the women are
women strong independent and equal or in
need of male headship and protection
can't be both pick one also Pearl the
pink dress looks beautiful on you thank
you Rachel Rachel actually guys you
should subscribe to her Channel she
actually is like the smartest woman I
have ever met when it comes to like
knowing the history of feminism feminism
very interesting woman
um Vinnie LT
if a woman keep kept a boyfriend for one
to two years maybe took a year off tell
her about 30 till 30 her body count
would still would probably be less than
10 get a boyfriend and keep him Shannon
if a college girl hooks up with two men
a month which is possibly which is
possible especially over spring and
summer break that's 24 year after after
four that's 96. um
204 D dollarization is happening Fast
Printing of money is happening fast in
the west and in five years it will lose
the edge it all comes down to the
bedroom
um
oh wait no this is out of order I see
Yumi World 204 um savitri negotiated
um to return her to her husband's Soul
the God had to bow down to her wish
because she was Sadie epitome of loyal
chaste pure the symbolism of Purity in
India has been the strength and coercion
of the family society and Nation D
dollarization is happening Fast Printing
of money is happening fast in the west
and in five years it will lose its Edge
it'll all come down to the bedroom the
war on meds started in the 60s long
before anyone was born
um and then let me refresh it real quick
um
and then okay we're okay
so and also I wanted to welcome our new
members we have the Haven project deck
Wolfgang towel
Rachel Fallen the memberships really do
help us on the channel
um it lets us like kind of increase our
expenses every month and you know expand
because we know we have we can rely on
those so appreciate that I do think I am
going to close out the show because
we've been going for like over two hours
now oh dang
um but thank you guys for coming
um do you want to do final thoughts MLG
um I just don't think that there is a
gigantic conspiracy of all men getting
together to try and like
like disenfranchise women I mean if
anything I think it's a bunch of well I
I think well actually if you look at the
root of it all and if the majority of
all the leaders and uh CEOs and
marketing directors trying to extort
women yeah maybe that's the real
you know like patriarchy or whatever but
um again like who's whipping out the
wallets who's spending the money you
know who's overeating you know all this
stuff who's falling for it right men are
the ones that are calling this [__] out
like how many how many women did you see
like rallying against the situation that
happened in 2020
you know a lot of them were on the other
side of the fence like you better get
the shot or you're a piece of [__] like
that's what I saw on social media and so
I just think that instead of just
blindly following along with whatever
social movement is put in front of you
just do a little research do a little
digging think for yourself don't be so
gullible just to believe the government
because I mean if you look at the
government the government's Legacy is
failure across the whole you know
Nations and everything so that's my
final thought
oh so my final thoughts are
definitely
accountability is free so I don't think
that people should be so adverse to
actually dealing with accountability in
all its forms and it helps us be better
people at the end of the day so in this
situation where we discussed essay and
grape
um yes it's it's a situation that isn't
always a fun time but I do think if all
individuals are aware of context and how
to keep themselves out of certain
situations I think we might all you know
come off better
um final thoughts is something I should
have mentioned earlier it's just I
really wanted to know it's going back to
the men and the body count and them
having
um a number and them saying no after
that number do you guys have any
experience with
either you asking or your friends asking
if they've been
with a black man
so basically
um making it about race yeah so I
I've not experience this personally but
um
a woman a guy would ask a woman have you
been with a black or brown man and if
it's a yes it's a no from him
I've heard of um certain situations like
that before
um I find those interesting and it
definitely
um comes from it being more or less I
don't want to say an inferiority complex
but it does there's definitely some kind
of complex going on there
I wouldn't say
um that is so to kind of have because at
the end of the day we're all human at
the end of the day so for someone to
single out
um people
specifically kind of speaks more to
their insecurities for lack of a better
word and whatnot
yeah have you heard of that uh Japanese
guys do that for foreigners they'd be
like hey have you ever been with a
foreigner before and then they look down
and they do yeah and they're just like
Ugh you know
what made you think about it's
um
that's been asked to you no no not
personally
um
it's been asked to me as have you ever
heard of this
and I've had to say no I've not heard of
it till that person told me about it and
then I heard it again from someone else
and I thought this must be a thing that
I've just not heard of before
um but was there a question sorry no
it's just your final thoughts I mean if
you're on any social media or anything
there's going to be a then uh
there's going to be a proportion of men
who the ones that go have you been with
a foreigner and then when they say they
have they don't like it
have you been with 10 women yes they
don't like it those men might be doing
it from an ego point
not all of them but the ones that say
have you been with a certain race and
then they look down on the woman for
doing it or have you been a certain
number and looked down
there are some men who will see those
two as the same sort of thing not all of
them
but there are a proportion of men
yeah
but there's loads of there's like like
we've said there's bad people everywhere
bad women bad men bad communication men
have been wanting sexual Purity since
like the dawn of civilization
and it's just like biologically enough
to you know that and that's why women
lie about it that's why Japanese women
lie about it Chinese women Indian women
you know Korean women American women
Brazilian women you guys are not all on
some like woman Network like
collaborating like Hey we're going to
collectively lie to men about this and
the same thing men are not collectively
like hey you know let's make sure we
oppress women for you know being hoes
it's just with the preference yeah you
know it's just a preference and I think
like it's just kind of Common Sense we
all know it but certain people make bad
decisions and then now they want a whole
social movement behind them to justify
their failures
yeah well I appreciate you guys for
coming
no kick outs tonight right yeah
all right guys
um like the video on your way out and
also really sign up for our Google Forum
we're going to be doing some events in
London also former show guests you know
sign up for the Google form if you want
to know when we're doing meetups
um also guys make sure you subscribe to
the channel we want to get to 2 million
by the end of the year so make sure you
hit that subscribe button uh we'll
probably be live I think Tuesday next
week to Friday I think we're looking at
so tune in then
uh we're also starting a new podcast
soon
um I think either next week or the week
after I'll let you know but like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
yo what's going on people King rich is
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's video Jenny's podcast it's your
boy The Fresh Prince of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you like not just
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do going out
having fun get out okay okay then then
get out then get out after after then
get out I'm not here to get canceled
today most men want a woman that has
some degree of femininity where they
feel like they're taken care of taking
care of and Lady night I'm submissive
and you'd be surprised because I will
say what I want to say now and I'll say
what I want to say with my mind but my
demeanor doesn't change and I'm gonna
look down on him because at the end of
the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened to
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I would feel so asking a guy
to buy like a three thousand dollar bag
now he's
foreign
[Music]